hello everybody hello hello oh my gosh finally we are here today to play sleeping dogs um basically it's like gta but um instead of la we're in hong kong so i've actually never played this game before um surprisingly um i did have a physical copy of it when it first came out um because you know I was like,
oh my God, um, um, you know, GTA Hong Kong, you know, I was like, oh my God, game based off of Hong Kong.
I was living in Hong Kong at that time as well.
So, um, I bought the game when it first came out.
Um, and then I try to play it.
Um, I try to play it by myself.
Like, uh, I don't remember, I think what console it was.
And for some reason, I stopped after 30 minutes because at I was like, single player is just not for me.
I was just like, it's not that fun playing single player games, you know?
Like, that was little me.
I was like, I was just like, oh, it's not that fun playing single player games by myself.
I guess I just, and then I just, I just like watching other people play.
Like, I just, I just remember that.
But now, now I'm okay.
Now, that's why, like, now on my YouTube channel, you see me play all these, like, games i never actually got a chance to play like all single player games because i am very like brain rotting when it came to comes to like multiplayer like i i just love multiplayer games when it comes to like um fps and shooters because like that's where like uh what gets me like super addicted um and like also like multiplayer in general is what gets me like super addicted to like video games um so but but when i stream these single player games i actually get to Enjoy them because I love I love streaming games in general like sharing like experiencing single-player games with you guys because it feels like multiplayer You know,
it's like you're sharing the experience with a group of friends Like like a group here like you know, so That's why I love going through all these single-player campaigns and everything on stream Because if I get stuck, I can ask you guys for hope too If I don't know what I'm doing,
I can be like what do I do so I can get backseated um so um I'm like one of those streamers I actually enjoy getting backseated instead of thinking for myself sometimes um when you guys said mute the music due to DMCA the most they do is just they they claim the video and then get my five like one like i don't know one percent of the ad revenue which i mean they get they get the ad revenue which is like what one dollar which is fine i don't need any of the music because um music claims is mostly just they they just take my ad revenue for the stream so like i'm fine with that i don't really care so yeah like this is technically my first time playing it blind um so um i've only I don't even remember the first 30 minutes of the game,
to be honest.
So it is going to be a blind reaction to the sleeping dogs.
Oh, Mushy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Add your revenue.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What I'm hoping for is that it's multiple music companies taking, claiming the ad revenue.
So they'll split the money.
They'll split that $1 to like five different companies.
So I hope that that's what happens.
So like they basically get nothing.
One George, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, here is five dollars, yeah, yeah, make them fight for the dollar, that's why whenever I do like, like, study streams or member streams, and I just don't care, like, I was like, oh, I'm gonna get,
like, if I'm just like, oh, I'm gonna get copyright claimed anyway, like, if I'm gonna get, like, copyright claimed, um, anyways, to, for my ad revenue, I'll just play, like, all the company music, like, I'll play, like, Disney instrumental, Nintendo instrumental,
like, I'll just, like, just fight for it, I don't care.
Like, just fight for this one fucking dollar.
So none of you actually get anything.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, my retro plush came in today.
Too bad, not home to get it.
So sad.
At least it's here.
Woo.
All the merch is arriving so fast.
Yeah, I'm happy about that.
Also, do I play this on controller or mouse and keyboard chat?
I was reading chat and people were like oh, yeah, like the gunplay for this is not like that good Like mostly people would just this fight.
Oh controller.
Okay.
I'll plug in my controller Because I wasn't sure if I'm playing if I should be playing controller or not because I was like well I would like to shoot my gun properly because I I cannot I honestly I'm I cannot aim my controller when it comes to like Shooting stuff.
So I just I just never really grew up with that.
So I'm just like it's just it's just very sad watching me try to aim in that silk song finally got announced i was not expecting it to come out in two weeks like i you know when you know when they're like supposed to announce a release date you would have like a couple of months to like get ready for the new game the fact that it comes out in two weeks is crazy like i thought i had enough time to like complete hollow night before before silk i mean Okay,
so next week, there's going to be a lot of Hollow Knight, because I'm going to try and complete Hollow Knight before we get into Silk Song.
The fact that it's like, two, it is, it is, the fact that everyone waited, like, how many years for Silk Song, and it feels like they just dropped it, like, I feel like they were, you know, they're like, we don't need enough average, we don't need more advertising or hype to hype it up.
Like, two weeks is good enough.
drop more trailers of silk song before it get and like tease it a little bit more before we get to like the actual drop but the fact that it's coming out in two weeks oh my gosh okay so like i promise i did promise you guys i would finish hollow night before we played silk song so next week we're gonna have like i don't know three to four streams of hollow night and see how it goes We'll see how much I can complete in three to four streams Because I do want to At least like I'll be warmed up You know I'll be I'll be warmed up for Silk Song Before it drops
This is what happens When you procrastinate with your homework Thank you for the super chat I can't believe Silk Song is real Oh my god I was not expecting that So next week, it's going to be lots of holiday.
So, but yeah, that's going to be next week's schedule.
Other than, but yeah, yesterday, I didn't stream yesterday because when I did the Mage Arena stream, I was coughing a lot.
I was coughing in bed too, when I was like, I was trying to sleep and I kept coughing myself awake.
And yesterday morning.
So I was like, I can't.
like rest my voice uh before then because i'm still a little at the aftermath of my sick of my um of my cold i guess so it's just i'm just coughing i'm better technically i'm okay i'm just coughing that's really it like it's just me expelling the leftover bacteria um so sorry for no no club penguin yesterday um we'll see how i'm not sure if i'll do club penguin next like i said i was gonna postpone it for next week but i'm like there's so much hollow that i have to do so i don't know i don't know if we have time for club penguin next week we'll see i still have time to figure this out we'll see um other than that uh the other thing i want to talk about was victory bell because what the okay i when i saw the picture of victory bell i was like what the
like um i don't know it's so the the trail i don't know you guys know this but everyone thought pokemon posted the wrong screenshot for their pokemon director something and they're like what the because it looked like a horror film um because they're like why is this a horror film screenshot on their pokemon twitter uh and and and then they did a parody they basically did like a horror movie parody where it was like um like a youtube parody where uh like a bunch of kids were exploring uh like an abandoned building and they were like trying to like figure out where like oh what ghost pokemon is and it was just victory bell but like for those who don't follow on pokemon this is the new mega evolution uh victory bell and uh so cody thank you for the mega uh sorry
took me a while to say it but here's some birthday funds for you happy late birthday to you joki oh thank you so much cody i really appreciate it oh my gosh oh thank you thank you cody thank you so much for the support it really does mean a lot but yeah so there were a lot of comments about the mega the mega is he choking himself so the reason why he's choking himself is because um he has too much in his belly but like why does he look happy about it that's like so he basically has acid reflex and the reason so he has to close his he has to choke himself so the acid doesn't like fall like like overflow so yeah he's a fucking he's he likes it yeah so yeah so like i i don't know i i there's just something that makes me a little uncomfortable and there's like so many things about it that there's just there's there's a lot of things that the culmination of like everything about him is just a bit uncomfortable like it's game freak for a reason yeah it's it's definitely pretty freak i i i i
don't there's i don't know me like just i like it's just that he's tying himself up, I guess, and the smile.
If you turn him his face upside down, he's just a happy Homer Simpson.
Eva, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Peter, thank you, super chat.
That new Mega looks so much like the first box and links to time.
Super, thank you, thank you, thank you.
At least it doesn't look as stupid as the Dragon Knight one.
I'm sorry.
Like, I don't know if this is a hot take.
But the dragonite one, he looks so fucking stupid like I'm I am not in I was not impressed when they did the the mega no, it's just okay Okay, let's see for those who never saw but at least we're talking about it.
I guess it's just I don't know They're just Take that back.
I It's just fucking weird I feel like because Dragon Knight is such a fan favorite I feel like they could have I don't know it's just there's something wrong there's a what do you mean it's literally it's just I there's just something wrong okay like there's something wrong with it
I feel like he deserved better.
That's all I feel.
At least the Mega Victory Bell looks better than Mega Dragon Knight.
Anyway, let's play Sleeping Dogs.
Wolf, wolf.
Alright, let me make sure that...
It just looks very silly, okay?
It just looks very silly.
Because if you look at, like...
I feel like the...
original the first mega evolutions they all looked very badass if you think about it the the first couple of mega evolution that they first came up they look incredibly badass because it's like mega evolution like fucking charizard got like you look silly like like you know mega charizard the mega charizard x and y they look like edgy as hell and like look really badass so i just i Um,
how silly Mega Dragonite or Mega...
What the fuck is Mega Audino?
Okay, let me look at Mega Audino.
I don't even remember what the fuck Audino is.
Mega Audino.
Did I got a Mega Evolution?
What the fuck?
Which...
Some head dev really...
This is a head dev.
Dev's like favorite fucking Pokemon right there.
Yeah, I was gonna be like, like, okay, but like you can't really make Ardino badass, not gonna lie.
That is somebody's Nepo baby right there.
Like what the fuck?
Who?
Who is it?
That is definitely some head Dev's like favorite Pokemon.
And they're like, but sir, what a...
But, sir, what about the other starters?
Like, no!
Milo Dino must be, must get a mega evolution.
Doki's just hating.
That's not true.
Someone's like, no, Charizard's the Nepo baby.
Charizard is everybody's Nepo baby, okay?
He's been a Nepo baby since he was fucking born.
Dev's Nepo baby.
You know, it's just one guy's baby.
Literally one person.
Charizard is an OG.
He deserved it.
He clawed his way into success.
No more electric rats.
All right.
He deserved it.
He is OG.
He is literally the president's son.
Charizard is all of our Nepo babies.
Who the fuck is on Dino's Netbo baby?
Alright, let's go.
Uh, let's play the main story.
Start a new game.
Hey, you're so tired of that lizard.
Seems like somebody got fucking shit on by the Netbo baby.
Uh, Therans, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fight back to school is a good movie.
It is.
It's one of my favorite Steven Child movies.
I've got it.
What?
How much money?
Oh, it's all in Cantonese.
Nice.
Okay, the subtitle is tiny as fuck.
I'm sorry, guys.
He's only... I'm not fucking blind.
Relax, old boy.
The one, the one guy that's...
That speaks English.
It's like a Russian... You know, like, like, you know how like they do like, oh, a Russian movie or like, and then they all speak English?
It's like, this takes place in Russia and then they all speak English.
Oh, that's true.
It's Hong Kong.
Everybody speaks English.
No, we speak, we speak like Canton English.
English knees.
Yeah, Russian with British accents.
Come, come, my friend.
Are you crazy?
No, don't.
Maybe we can sort something out, huh?
Yeah, do you know who I...
Oh, shit!
He's like, did you know who I am?
And then he gets shamed.
Oh, bro!
With a butcher knife?
Oh my god!
That shit is crazy.
We'll never know who he is.
That's true.
Who was he?
What the meat cleaver?
Where I see that?
Okay, follow Nans.
I got you now.
Oh, shit.
Wait, no, never mind.
I forgot how to sprint, apparently.
Alright.
I'm trying my best!
Oh, my God.
Do I hold it?
Okay, I can hold.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got you.
I'm going the fastest I can!
Stop him!
Please, he's a criminal!
Okay.
Yeah, I'm the Hong Kong police.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Respect my authority.
I won't go to Casa Bonita.
Oh shit!
I'm sorry, I was looking at Casa Bonita yesterday.
Do you know they have like a waitlist?
Right now for like Casapunita.
Oh my god, I'm sorry guys.
I'll pay for it.
I swear to God with my very, very high police salary.
Wait, I thought I was a good guy.
Wait, what?
I wasn't?
Oh shit, no, I was doing a drug deal.
Yeah, I was...
He's basically giving him his rights.
I did it.
I thought he was an undercover cop.
Yes, he there you go.
English knees Oh shit Jackie Ma It is you I can't fucking believe it What are you doing here When did you get back Wait Man you look like shit Hey fuck you You know 15 years or do that You know we're not kids anymore Whatever man Ask anyone Jackie Ma Still looks good Whoa Oh Lucy Lou is in here Good to see you What the fuck?
They finally deport your ass from the United States?
That was mutual.
Time I came home anyway.
Oh, that's why I speak mostly English.
Home, sweet home.
Okay, bring up, over on, bring down.
Okay.
Nothing that'll stick.
Well, don't let them pin any extra shit on you.
Emma Stone's in here?
Let me tell you.
Once they hear you're from old prosperity, happens all the time.
Hey, so you still in touch with any of the guys from there?
A few, you know.
Well, that's why I speak mostly English.
He's from the United States.
He's moved all the way up to Red Pole and the Sun on Yee.
I've got a couple of things going with him right now, matter of fact.
Huh.
Red Pole and the Sun on Yee.
Shit.
Dog Guys always said he'd be running that neighborhood.
Oh, Dog Guys is a Red Pole too.
It's still a total poke guy.
Ha ha ha ha.
Okay, I'll say poke guy is worse than asshole.
It's a lot worse than hassle.
It's a very bad word.
Wade fucking Shen in the flesh.
I can't believe it.
Jackie.
Looks like I'm out of here.
Hey, Jackie.
So look, if you and Winston ever need help with any of that shit you got going on with him.
Of course, man.
Look me up when you get out.
Just be like old times.
Nice.
Yay, Jackie's freed.
What does it mean?
It's like the Mel equivalent of the C word.
Like, if I ever...
If I say that in front of my parents, I'd get slapped.
It seems that the evidence against you is failed to appear.
How do you explain that?
You must be a very dangerous man, Wei Shen.
what we want people to think i trust that my men weren't too rough on you officer you might ask them the same question sir oh oh you had to like oh he got in what it's jackie ma whatever it takes he's your friend you'll report everything through him our intel suggests that winston is looking for muscle yeah he a cop way to make him trust you he's undercover car in hong kong american gangs even Asian ones don't compare to the triads here the Sun on ye is the most powerful Raymond your name is Raymond right yes I grew up with these guys I know who they are what they are all the Intel reports in the world won't give you that we'll turn up the volume after the cutscenes done most of all the dragon head candidly way previous attempt I can't do it now actually hand out we don't have much to go on that's why you're here I'm hoping that you can bring something more to our investigation i understand sir look the sooner i'm on the street yeah he has the tats to prove that he's hardcore look at
him raymond will be he got the tattoos but like during undercover or after before undercover yeah it doesn't like any tab out respectfully sir are you sure about him he'll be under extreme stress maybe for a very long time now i'm not sure he has the discipline to hold up according to the file he has a history of extreme behavior yes and an astonishing number of convictions he obviously blames a twice for what he's a very good mythic actor oh wait what the trash killed his family is perfect for this job yeah in like hong kong detective movies the head guy is usually always a british white man for some reason there's always like the like the foreigner is like the head of something it's always in that in the hong kong movies I tried looking you up a few years back,
but I couldn't find shit.
Do they have internet in America?
I think they're getting it next year.
I guess you were in prison or something.
Come on, let's get out of here.
Still getting used to being back, huh?
Okay, let's...
Wow.
I was not expecting that for the settings.
All right, options, audio, sound effects.
All right, let me know if it's better, sound guy.
okay yeah there's no internet in america apparently i can't believe it oh my god i'm so oh i missed this oh that's so cool that looks so good australian lobster that is not give me australian lobster that is not a south african lobster where the fuck where's the lobster in there let's just duck my barbecue duck oh it looks so good that looks so good but yeah I was like where the fuck is my lobster I would need to see my lobster if I'm gonna eat it let me do the introductions they're really distrustful of new faces right now it's wild paranoia son on ye had a rat from what I hear they didn't let him have a quick Ooh,
yeah, no NARCs allowed.
I'll have to go TC now.
He's like, you're crazy.
I was like, how is he crazy?
That's right.
I'll never do that, Jackie.
I ain't no NARC.
Anyway, how old are you?
Like, can I have your first, middle, and last name plus your maiden's name?
You just don't even know me.
Once we get to know each other, they'll love me.
Okay,
the subtitle is like not that accurate.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I can press X.
Let's go.
Okay.
One, two, and then one.
One, oh my god, one, two, hold, one, two, hold, one, two, oh my god, I'm fucking it up.
I'm fucking up the most, it's just all X's and I still managed to fuck it up.
Okay.
I'm playing Tekken right now.
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, I'm just spamming X's.
You kidding me?
Yeah, all right.
Come the fuck.
Yeah, come on.
Whoa, whoa.
That's right.
Who taught you how to say that?
What will your parents say?
Wait, I can sprint.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to do that again.
That's right.
Say hello to that wall.
Hey, say hello to this wall, too.
That's right.
I'm going to take you to all the doors.
That's looking right.
Boom.
That's right.
That door's made a seal.
I want to take your shoes too.
I don't know if...
Hit it, run.
Boom.
Knock, knock.
That's right.
I don't know if this does any damage at all.
Get grappled.
Get over here.
That's all.
Take you to the other side.
That's right.
You think only that door is safe?
No.
No doors are safe.
That's right.
Knock, knock.
Boom.
Oh, sorry.
I had to do that one first before.
All right.
Wrong door.
I was supposed to take you over here.
Did
I do an America?
I'll go get him joking Zachary's like you were in the super chat thank you thank you What the fuck did I learn in America guys So everything's cool Yeah everything's cool What the hell then Let's go see Winston Holy damn That boy ain't right He went to America look what happened
I'm about pay off the cops That's what I learned in my movies this is way wayshen i told you about him remember we can't keep track of your bullshit friends jackie no outsider he's not an outsider he's from old prosperity yeah yeah it's like us old prosperity
wow yeah jackie said you were looking for people Oh, jack you, dog.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You should have seen it, Winston.
Wait, just beat up, like, 10.
Yeah!
I ran over people with my grapple.
Seems to me you could use some better help.
Wait, come on, yeah, huh?
Winston, I don't like this dog.
What the?
But he actually said, what are you saying?
Dang, Yat-san, I do remember you.
You had a...
Sister, right, Hamaya?
Yeah.
Me, me, me, Shand.
I remember her.
It was like, was she hot?
I was with all guys.
No offense.
Don't know.
So, Topalga.
Oh.
Where is she now?
She dead?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Sorry.
Oh, you see her.
So, oh, my God.
She is dead.
Guys, huh?
That's why he hates the triads, because she got close to the triads.
Uh-huh.
We'll see.
Convoy.
You know that problem we got in the market, why don't you take away with you?
So there's still a chance, like, where is she buried?
Hey, Jackie, hang back a second.
I want to hear more about your friend.
But is she still hot?
You want to be a tough guy?
Let's see if you can handle yourself.
Dude, see what he's got.
Great.
That's all I fucking need.
All right.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, counter.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, you like that?
Yeah?
I could do it again.
Yeah, you'll do it again?
Man, that's okay, right?
Get countered.
Survive the hazing?
Oh, I just have to keep...
Wait, why won't you let me grapple?
God, that's fucking right.
Yeah, that's right.
I'll do a dick punch if I have to.
Do it again.
That's fucking right.
Do that again.
Survive for 28 seconds.
Oh, wow.
Guys, it's so difficult, guys.
You think they're going to try and punch me again?
Oh, my God.
What will they do?
It's like...
Damn.
I'm going to try that again.
Yeah, that's okay, right.
Keep doing that.
The most difficult game of my life.
It's like yellow paint, but red outline.
Like how the trans...
The substance is like, what the fuck are you doing?
But he literally was just saying, what are you doing?
Winston, my old friend, so good to see you.
The Eldrinko got nothing on me.
Oh, Winston.
Wait, wait, wait.
But yeah, don't keep bringing him to his Cantonese.
Oh, that's so good.
That's so good.
We can share the night market, huh?
We're both Songong Yi.
Both grown men.
We shouldn't be fighting like children.
Get on your Cantonese.
Hey, who's the new blood?
It's Wei.
I'm from America.
Back when you first started getting girls with big smiley.
Oh, Mimi.
Oh, that's...
Oh, that's awkward.
Ways are brother.
And I was the first guy who ever stabbed me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, what the fuck, man?
Seriously, way?
I apologize.
I'm really sorry.
Your sister blew me.
Yeah, she had a bad choice of men, clearly.
You guys see who are in the warehouse.
That was the deal.
So stay the fuck.
ow hey tell your sister give me a call huh i wouldn't mind giving her a mouthful damn let's watch he hasn't changed yeah he is used to be my friend jackie you took gold to the night market you make sure people understand that i'm in control not dog eyes got it got it boss moment and you up anybody who tries to get in your way i want to send a fucking message wait what's the message this will be easy no problem oh my god is it chinese new year oh my god it's the lion dance let's go
wait what we moved to the stage to try to kick that ship but she oh deed oh my gosh that sucks bro you know yeah oh wait that's me he said hey Oh, she was an addict because of the triads.
Damn.
I thought she, like, died by the triads, like, in terms of, like, I don't know.
Like she was in the wrong crowd with the triads.
Paxton punch and crease her melee.
Oh, it's only for $30 Hong Kong dollars.
That's like five American dollars.
Not bad.
Oh, noodles.
Full health regeneration.
Where's my pork buns?
Good suit?
I want good suit.
Is that my bootleg Louis Vuitton suit right there?
Oh, this is like...
What's the word?
This is like very nostalgic for me.
walking down this this area oh my god now that collect money oh now that is nostalgia right there where's my where's my brown box of pirated dvds
i need like the little brown cardboard box you don't want trouble you pay him period of course no problem that's right you need anything Go to the watch vendor.
Where's the watch vendor?
Really?
For me?
I have to go this way.
Yeah, we're...
Yeah, in the plastic sleeves.
Where's my bullet DVDs in the plastic sleeves?
Oh, bush dumplings!
Oh, oh my god, it looks so good.
Oh, this is so nostalgic.
Going through here.
Lots of memories.
Oh, man, it's high.
What made it?
Oh, it's just vegetables.
Oh, my God.
There's a deal.
There's a pot.
Ice cream?
Basic, briefly, at last.
Oh, I want ice cream.
Can I have some ice cream?
Yeah, the best.
Delicious.
That health regeneration, guys.
All right.
I'm going to get my Bolex watch real quick, guys.
We're collecting for Winston.
Winston?
Don't I said he's in trust here.
We're here to clarify that.
Yeah.
You want to be the guy we use to clear up the confusion?
I'm not afraid you guys.
You're not?
That's it.
Get over here.
Oh, that's your son?
That's fucking right.
Get in this phone booth.
Someone call the police, but not for me.
That's right.
Now you have to pay for your son's medical bills.
Now get me a Bolex watch!
I'm glad I can make you see reason.
Collect the call.
Nice.
Violent actions against...
I like how nobody cared.
They all know.
That's right.
They all fucking know.
Oh.
Did I kill him?
Did I?
There's no.
No, he's breathing.
You know?
Just barely.
Oh, whoops.
What?
Yeah, say that to my face.
That's right.
Walk away, bitch.
That's fucking right.
I went to America.
I see shit.
Wait, there's a health shrine?
Duki, I don't think he's moving.
Wait, there's a health shrine here?
You're getting too far from Jackie.
That's right.
Don't even look at my face.
That's looking right.
This ain't no British colony right now.
We were...
We Americans rebelled against the British colony.
Okay.
Alright.
Give me the money.
We should have never killed anyone.
Josh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Everyone has business with Winston.
You're gonna pay up.
You understand?
Go tell Winston to stick a back toy up his ass.
What did you fucking say?
Alright, where is he?
That's right!
Get over here!
Get your fucking get in the box!
That's right!
Okay.
No, you ain't.
Give me a sec, guys.
I'm heading into the other box.
You think your punches will get me?
That's right.
Someone packed up.
It's moving day.
Oh, I'm fucking heading over to your bok choy now.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to the wall next to your bok choy.
That's fucking right.
You think I care?
I can take those hits.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Wait, there's a shutter?
Where's the...
Oh, I'm gonna cut you in half, little boy.
Oh, never mind.
We'll put you in the pineapple then.
Oh, there's a...
There's apparently a red shrine somewhere.
Where is that?
Give me a...
Oh, I'm getting too far.
God damn it, Jackie.
I need to go to my rich ride.
Oh, shit.
That's right.
Wait.
Wait, I could take her.
All right, get over here.
I need to use the shutter.
Give me a sec.
There's an environment right there.
That's what you're...
Get over here.
There you go.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
I have three strikes.
It's okay.
As long as I don't... As long as I don't do the third strike.
You saw that?
She wasn't even part of it.
You fucking saw that?
She tried to sell me Red Bull.
That's fucking right.
You saw Dog Eyes do that before?
You didn't.
Isn't that?
She's fine.
She'll just drink some Red Bull later.
Oh, isn't that?
Is that the...
the rich ride?
Oh, it is.
It's fine, right?
No!
It's fine.
I... Like, technically I didn't kill anyone.
No, that's why I'm such a neem, I can mention.
Never stick you with a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, point point!
Oh my god, you heard that?
No pork about pork fan.
You're not a whole man.
You're right.
You're so right.
And I get rewarded with some pork buns.
Let's go.
He said nothing.
Can I just grab this guy?
Whoa, hey, what's going on here?
Only I can, that's right, get in this vending machine.
Oh my God, get over here.
Oh, shit, you thought you could do that?
Get your ass over here.
That's fucking right.
Oh my God, you think I didn't see you?
All right, get over here.
I have another environment to pick you in.
And man, that's fucking right.
Oh, you see that?
You see that?
Oh, yes, you did.
I'm going to cut you in half.
Oh, just because...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I have enough HP for this.
Slam!
Hostile down.
Alright.
Is there any environment next to me?
Oh, you're so lucky.
That's right.
belongs to fucking me oh i mean winston now give me your money i like he's like oh my hero now give me my money come on this lab it's time to close the shop drug addicts will make sure you don't have trouble with gangsters that sounds very amazing my hero oh clothing stall where's the clothing You're like,
come over here.
It's not here.
Why is he?
Oh, shit, sir!
I was just so used to grabbing.
Okay, here, let go.
Just let go.
Come on.
Just grapple it off.
Oh, my God, you're so weak in front of your girlfriend.
You're so weak.
That's right.
I'll slowly walk over.
Don't worry.
I got your girl.
Got your boyfriend right here.
Come back.
Come back for your...
Come back for your boyfriend.
I got him.
He's right here.
He's...
Don't worry.
I can take him over to her.
Okay, there you go.
See, now you can be reunited.
He's so weak.
She ain't loyal.
Can I interest you in some better clothes?
Yeah, I can.
I like some better clothes, please.
What do I have?
The knockoff hang dot plus sweetie neck.
Oh, I want a wife beater or a knockoff hang.
Let's see.
My other, wear the shoes, pants.
Wait.
Okay, wear the shoes, pants, and shirt to do plus five.
Okay, what?
What?
That's what it is.
It's a white shirt.
That's what they're called!
You guys not know that?
That's what they're called, the undershirt.
That's literally what they're called.
Face one required?
Oh, they're not half the face?
Okay.
I don't know what I want.
What the fuck is this?
The...
Elegant, but not too flashy.
what to get i don't know let's get the church chair now i look now i'm in style now i'm gonna oh look i look just like jackie ma
oh ming pie they have like designer stuff that was awesome man all this teen teen teen it's like you were born to do this hey jackie Yeah, what's going on?
Just keeping an eye on things.
Yeah, would you see I tell you what I didn't?
Oh my god, the stride!
Fuck.
I got too I got too engrossed in the plot You fuck up what we're gonna throw down.
Yeah What kind of grade school?
I thought it's three strikes.
I work my ass off all day So fuck off and grow up Jackie You're coming with me.
We got something to take care of But we're all wearing the same thing.
It's the volume a lot better now, guys.
Okay, now.
Cop and try to score a war to experience towards your next game levels to purchase new upgrades.
Oh, I could have more cop experience.
Okay.
Alright, where's the...
Alright, so this...
Okay, we got a game phase by doing favors.
for people.
Okay, we gotta find the Blinkie Blink shrine.
Is it back here?
Oh, it's here.
Alright.
I like my incense and pray to the gods so I don't go into that.
So I don't get judged to be in hell.
And...
Oh, can I...
Do I get another ice cream?
Hmm.
So tempting.
It's so tempting to get more ice cream.
Hello.
Oh, it feels like Hong Kong with how everybody's talking.
Mrs. Chu sent over some lunch, but I haven't paid yet.
Can you take this back to the restaurant?
All right.
All right, cool.
I heard all guys are sending reinforcements.
You should probably be gone before they get here.
Okay, don't worry, I got you.
So gangster.
Yeah, I rolled up with my popsicle before I beat you up oh shit sorry how do i let go i haven't learned that yet i just know how to grapple it's okay ma'am i'm just taking you to your destination faster guys i didn't learn to i oh guys i can't let her go i'll take you i'll take you don't worry you're gonna come with me i am i pressed it again she won't let go all right there you go my human shield oh wait I could have used this as my human shield all right nice yeah you saw that yeah I'm fucking crazy oh my god he called me ass phase that's it before someone called the ambulance for this man because I'm pretty sure he's dead all right sound check oh my god There's another one.
Give me a sec.
I gotta punch him in the dick first.
Alright, I'll take you over here.
They said Red Bull gives you wings.
Let's test that out.
When you go to heaven.
That's right.
Oh, wait.
That's hardcore.
Let's get all the windows.
There's enough windows for the...
There's enough windows.
That's right.
Two more to go.
Stop with the one ladder
Oh no, I ran out of windows Don't worry, I saw one more We're remodeling They said break the class if there's an emergency
They're stuck Okay, let's put him through this cave that guy is dead all right adoki is the emergency okay i did it nice all right no he'll be okay he just won't be in the walk but that's all right this is for susan's lunch thanks it's just like my steven chow movies
Just like my Steven Chow movies.
Alright, let's see.
Nice.
$12 for people.
Oh my god, bro.
Okay, I think he might not be okay.
I destroyed all her windows just for $12.
Bump, bump, bump, bump.
Oh wait, I have to go back here.
Your OS is slowing up.
Please wait while I'm up.
your window the slab okay I had to go this way oh my god he's still there wait they're both still there did I do a bad thing no I'm a cop we can't do bad things
Ross take you to the super chat thank you thank you nothing nothing say much the mole I came straight to you didn't want to start anything major but without you knowing you know so get this a couple This guy Ming came to me and asked me to look out for why he did business.
I am the law, exactly.
I thought, why not?
I'll take a nice little cut for my boys.
If I do all of this, that means technically I could legally murder someone because I'm an undercover cop.
And they were like, why did you do it?
And I was like, I had to make sure I played my part.
You know, I didn't want to be, I didn't want to be exposed.
You know, I gotta, I had to do it.
And you're like, but that guy wasn't like, But that guy wasn't even, like, in the triads, right?
It's like, no, you don't understand.
He was there.
He was part of the secret files in the triads.
That's Kwan for Ming's...
Oh, wait, what's this?
Oh, I got collectible.
I just, like, killed some random guys.
Like, you don't understand.
He was, like, part of the...
The triads told me to do it.
And if I didn't, they would know I was a cop.
Oh my god, you're having a fight.
He doesn't respect her with the waiters.
He doesn't respect them.
Oh my god, it's Dim Sum!
Oh wait, that's not...
Oh, it's the lobster!
It's the South African lobster right there!
There it is!
It's like half Dim Sum and half like non-Dim Sum.
Okay, I go downstairs.
Alright, where is he?
Where's being's whereabouts?
As you cross through, you'll unlock new police.
Use your phone to access them.
This is my phone?
Oh.
It's not a lot.
What the fuck?
Oh, there you go.
The main point of contact.
Oh, it's like the little, like, the little wiki.
Can I call people?
Wait, I don't have any friends?
Oh.
What about my social hub?
You didn't compare your stack game with your friends.
oh hey there's my stats with dokeybird and only dokeybird have some extra funds for you dokeybird kodi thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you oh cool look at me and dokeybird go
this is me and dokeybird me myself and dokey all right let's go talk to min How bad is it if I start Um Harassing the bystanders I'm looking for Ming You know where he's at Yeah He just passed the food stand around the corner Okay Confront Min is It's a He's over here Okay Do I get punished for it?
You make it up for me tonight And we got a deal I'll just say I was role playing I said triad oh shit how did he know is it because of my wife being a shirt how did he know oh my god shortcut okay I'm coming for you that's right you can't run away from me I know all the shortcuts get out of here did that give it away that's okay right get over here I just want to talk peacefully get your ass here oh wait we're okay I jumped the wrong way oh my god your store your store is fucking me over right I just want to talk with my fist is that so much to ask for it oh wait he stopped for me that's nice of him come on you cannot run me you know that i'm younger i went to america
oh that's a lot of environment get over here store is closed oh it's hot in it let me turn on the air condition
Okay, give me a...
Is there any more?
Aw.
Alright, let's just throw him.
Let's just throw him against the wall.
Get out.
Come on.
You're so lucky there's no more environments left.
You're so lucky.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I'm too busy trying to throw you against the wall.
Fuck.
Come on.
This...
Apparently, this is the only wall I can use.
Give me a sec.
I can't use any other wall.
I gotta use this one.
Get out of here!
Donowald!
Nice.
Alright.
Saw that?
Oh, Tudor.
You know what you are?
You belong...
You belong in the trash!
All right.
It's one of Winston's guys.
Pick him out.
Deal with him.
How are you?
Fuck you up.
Oh, you really want to fucking deal with me?
Oh, shit.
Oh, he does.
All right.
I guess I can't.
Unless there's an invite.
Oh, there is.
Give me a sec.
We gotta turn off the aircon.
Get over into the vent.
you go oh my god is he okay are you guys sure i don't kill anyone i
guys i'm having a harder time believing that now it was electrifying
it's getting harder and harder to believe maybe okay maybe it was just like flesh wound you know i think i just barely missed the brain oh man can you give me a sec i need this kill there you go into the vents you go it'll be fine all right give me a sec boss all right that's it oh that's fucking it get that knife out of there okay come on let me fucking grab you
you bitch i'm gonna knock that knife out of you oh fuck okay maybe he's gonna okay wait i'm spamming it too much all right there you go as soon as this knife is out get over here come on he doesn't want to die he saw what i did
all right get up You don't need an arm.
But I'm done with you.
Dog guys, you're going to kill you.
Fuck dog guys.
Winston owns this area.
You fuck with us, and you regret it.
Okay, okay.
But please, make sure dog guys doesn't kill me.
Ah, why'd that walk?
Guys, it's okay.
I always roll up there.
Guys, cops, cops.
It's okay.
I was just role-playing, guys.
Wait, Shane?
I'm Inspector Taylor.
You have quite a rap sheet here.
Multiple arrests in San Francisco, alleged ties to organized crime.
And now you're here enforcing for the sun on ye.
You know, you don't have to throw your life away like this.
Your concern's really moving.
I appreciate that.
I'm just laughing, guys, for the triads.
I could have made it.
I could have been a real somebody.
for showing me the light officer i want to give you a chance shen but you have to work with me then maybe is this lucy lou oh superintendent i'm in the middle of an interrogation inspector there's been a misunderstanding misunderstanding sir as your superior officer i'm instructing you to release this man but sir i have it on record that he's sun on ye i understand that i can't simply just cut him loose i mean you're asking me to release a criminal with known connections to the triad and not only is it against protocol and he's one of us What just like that let me get the door.
There are a few badges outside who didn't hear you.
It's all right I just met her.
Yeah, congratulations tanks and now you know maybe now you don't even know like how like how how do we know She's not a narc?
Yeah, it doesn't seem like I have much of a choice.
No, he talks me Yeah, so far permission to speak freely denied You need to be more careful way much more careful.
I can't bail you out like this again I just got doxed.
Just be careful.
I can't help it.
There are so many environmental kills around me.
You want me to not put that man in the vent?
It's right there.
I know she's in or out.
I don't like this cockatoo fucker.
You need to be more careful, Ray.
Much more careful.
I was so careful.
I was so, I mean, I was so careful, guys.
Like, yeah, I might have, like, ruined some property damage, but, like, I was so fucking careful with it.
Contains a bed, wardrobe, and CCTV that can access hacked cameras.
Wait, what?
That can access hacked cameras?
That's, like, crazy.
Wait, can I just sleep?
I'm meepie.
Good night.
I broke those windows very carefully.
Yeah, exactly.
I carefully killed those guys to make sure they had a painless death.
Good night.
Okay, there it is.
This is where the GTA comes in.
Okay, stick up a new case available.
Oh, that's her face, right?
is for favors i'll just do some favors real quick wait where are the hands oh massage parlor i need to go there gotta get it gotta get something real quick guys i'm feeling awfully stressed now
okay sir did my massage yeah it's highly literally asking me to do it i'm sure feeling very very stressed out guys I gotta I gotta get a massage all right oh hey don't see this
hello as long as I can oh shit sorry
go yet yeah i do i have my bike oh my 270 i still don't know how to let go all right okay i need a where's my massage oh it's over there all right my muscles are aching guys you don't understand this is very important
Let's go.
Hello.
Can I get a massage?
Look, it says sharpen senses and make your face meter feel.
Look, all I'm saying is that this is an investment.
Hey, baby, looking for a little adventure.
Might as well try everything once, right?
You got a favorite country way, France, Greece.
Meep, thank you for the 10 gift and chips.
Thank you, thank you.
It's for...
You just have to find a new job.
You know what they say about...
Okay, all I'm saying, I was very stressed out.
And now, now I'm okay now.
Now...
Wow, I feel so relaxed now, guys.
I feel...
I sure do feel really relaxed from that massage.
She was very thrill.
Alright.
A flashing thing.
I think that's, like, where my map is, isn't it?
I'm pretty sure.
No, I'm pretty sure that's where my map says.
Oh, wait, it is flashing.
Wait, you're right.
Wait, why is it flashing?
Is that an item?
Was that an item over there?
Oh, it was!
$50,000?
Oh my god, wait.
Why was it for the massage?
Guys, see?
Everything always.
You got $50,000.
I told you.
I told you guys it was an investment.
I can get so many massages now.
Gonna get it.
That was a very.
happy ending.
That was a very, very happy ending.
I told you it was worth it and you guys didn't believe me.
Hey, mister.
You got a moment?
Do you think this shirt is too tight?
Whoa.
Wait, was that, is that it?
Wait, what?
I will teach you to be a friend.
Oh, my buddy!
Wait, oh, yeah, it's just $500.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
He cashed a peep and teach him a...
Okay, to be fair, it's only...
Like, it's $500 from my $50k.
Like, do I really care?
Like, I really care about that.
You know, I had $50k in my pocket and he only took $500.
That's... That's on him.
I...
All of these...
Oh, he doesn't know who I am.
Say hello to my little friend.
The wall.
You know, I heard they're gonna build a wall.
Alright.
$500 is $500.
Nice.
My face experience.
And I got my $500 back.
The wall slammer.
You know, they did tell me about the Great Wall of China.
I don't think this is what the- this is the wall they're talking about, though.
Oh, there's another- there's another massage parlor.
Gosh, my bones are- all my bones are aching right now.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Where is it?
It's over here.
What a day.
All right, it should be like, where is she?
Where's my...
Oh, there she is.
Hello.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, who could resist you?
I know, right?
Good investment.
I promise.
No regrets here.
I almost got robbed.
Like, time for a massage.
Where do I actually have to go?
Okay.
Stick up and delivery.
What's the difference between stick up and delivery in the case file?
know where my bike is.
Fuck.
Oh, pay hospital bills.
Uh, fuck it.
I have 50k.
It doesn't really matter.
I'm gonna steal a car.
I don't know where my bike is.
All right.
It's time for the GTA part.
On the GTA.
It's okay.
I'll be fine.
It's time to borrow a car.
I'm a cop.
Give me your car.
Wee.
Okay, let's see.
Where do I...
Alright, let's...
Let's pay the hospital bill.
Wee.
Police pilot.
That's a bike.
Yay.
I look so stupid.
on this tiny little bike.
I know I look so goofy.
Okay, how do I get up there?
It's like...
Oh my god.
This is some good
music after for a post massage not gonna lie whoops it's fine i don't get hurt from this
all right i'm almost there oh there's the night market
all right it's like this way time to pay for some hospital days hello is too suggested i talk to you she a friend of mine i need a favor what do you need yeah my husband is in the hospital and i can't pay the bill the only thing we have of any value is our car you want to sell it no i i want you to run it in the harbor run the car into the harbor bro i have 50k i can give you some of that money okay where's your car all right it's time to drive this oh is he okay don't worry i can pick you up oh not you sorry give me a sec i don't know how to let girl I'm sorry don't worry you can just let go it's okay I don't I'm sorry I don't know how to let go I'm sorry oh wait there's okay let me pick this up real quick oh I can't pick it up just just come on you got this girl you got this oh it's why okay nice wait what's this What is this?
Oh, it's more money.
Nice.
I deserve that.
I don't know why I get out of here.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
Was that your girlfriend?
It was an accident.
I swear.
Oh, wait.
The car's already broken.
What the fuck?
Who destroyed the car already?
All right.
Where's the harbor?
Will I drive this car?
the harbor for insurance fraud let's go my favorite type of fraud
all right i mean it's like almost there i feel like i'm not allowed to like get the car in a crash or something or it's actually gonna blow up oh they're on bomb all right here i'll go we i did it that is two thousand dollars all right now let's do the mission
that's okay i wanted to i wanted the real experience it makes it more real if i if i'm in the car when it's in the ocean that's a whole ass massage that's more than that's like five massages right there all right let's go do the actual missions uh well here is closer we There's so many scooters and bikes now in China.
It's like everywhere.
It's very convenient, though.
You can, like, rent scooters, too.
Yeah, it's very popular.
Hello.
What do you need help for?
What do you need?
A ride.
Wait in a second.
Okay.
Wait for Calvin.
Oh, shit!
what the hell it's okay i have this is your car get in the car calvin
are you stupid i know gotta have a getaway red really appreciate it craig said and my giraffe what the fuck okay i can ram this she's not exactly my girlfriend i really like her though she's got a nice smile dress is real nice You're not even dating her?
Not yet, man.
Yeah, it's not yet.
It takes time.
Son of a bitch.
Is she with that guy?
You mean like right now?
Come on.
We're son on ye.
Cuts don't want anything on us.
Fucking exactly.
Oh my god, please.
I don't think I could get Calvin.
Your car fucking sucks.
What is this?
A goddamn broken up Honda?
Holy shh.
Never mind.
This car was much more built than I expected it to be.
Oh my god, never mind, Calvin.
Never mind.
Apparently I had a six-pack under the engine.
It had the ram attack.
Apparently, it's like those like robot, you know, like those like mini robots attacking each other.
No, I don't, why am I fucking driving?
Get over here.
Get too much.
Okay.
Here we go.
Get over here.
Get your ass.
Oh, shit.
He's fucking...
What the fuck?
He has a gun?
Oh, my God.
I was not expecting the gun.
The battle box.
Yeah, it's battle cars right now.
I did not expect a gun.
I did not expect you to pull out a gun on me.
He's got a gun.
I need to hit a cop.
I know who to call.
That's why you're pulled over.
Alright.
Yeah.
Alright, Calvin.
Goodbye.
The cops have guns.
Can I still ram?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Oh!
He's okay.
I don't have a strike.
So I technically I didn't kill anybody.
Okay, it's this way.
God, the sensitivity is so...
It's so...
Guys, I didn't get a...
I didn't get minus one police badge, so he's alive.
Never killed anyone, by the way.
But it's this way.
Whoops.
It's this way.
The car killed him, not me, guys.
It's the car company's fault.
Not me.
It's like the thing about...
like tesla cars if like the auto driver killed someone if the car the auto driver killed someone like is it really the driver's fault or the car's fault i had auto drive on guys i have autopilot on different you don't know that
Boom!
Oh, Nimi, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you.
I've had a great stream!
All right, I wasn't committing any murder.
I'm just... I'm just larping right now.
Don't worry, I'm a cop.
What are you doing here?
I'm sure you and Pendu have a lot of top-secret backdoor business to attend to.
I'm sorry about how I acted in there.
Yeah, I'm just larping.
I have to be convincing.
I'll see what I can dig up.
How's that for an olive breast?
Be serious.
Just like that.
I'll help where I can.
I'm just a little shocked.
I'm just used to Pinterest people being more like him.
I just think we'd be better off helping each other.
Come on, what do you say?
Oh my god, wait, he has a tattoo of fucking Guan Yun on his shoulder.
Wait, that's hardcore.
Mike, thank you for the gift of chip, aka, thank you Give the gift to ship.
Thank you.
I have a friend now.
Look.
Look at that.
Winston wants me to check up on you.
Everything cool.
Look at that.
See?
Friends will check up on friends.
Look at that.
Let me text my friend back.
Oh, okay.
Okay, never mind.
Apparently I don't have this number.
We're not as close as we thought we were.
Oh, wait.
Me and me at the market.
Noodle shop.
Okay.
Oh, I can't see it.
You're... Oh, you guys don't know.
Thank God.
Okay.
No, I had so many friends my contacts i had like 10 at least okay dragon head okay dragon head's the main bad guy all right let's see we gotta go meet up with him at the noodle shop hot shot pop star how do i leave oh it's over here i was like am i locked in it's over here there's the door Alright,
is there like any cars?
Oh yeah, there's my car.
Alright, time to head to the noodle shop, guys.
Let's go.
Oh, sorry.
Don't fuck with me.
I'm just giving him a little scare, you know?
Oh, shit, money!
Give me a sec.
I got Get the money first.
Just sending a message.
Oh, wait.
Is this pork buns?
Oh, Kale Yudan.
All right, we gotta have it.
Kale Yudan is so good.
Curry fish balls is iconic.
An iconic Hong Kong cuisine right there.
Yum, yum.
It's almost as good as pork buns.
All right, let's go.
meet me i always forget it's here let's go meet up with oh wait no this is closer is a shrine oh there is a shrine all right let's grab the shrine real quick yeah we gotta get the extra hp i did though what you more go fight it down That's like the only chat I know.
I like the incense.
Okay, I'll grab my bike.
That's really the only chat I know of the incense.
All right,
let's go.
Yeah, it's from Jackie.
Chan Adventures, which, by the way, is not even voiced by Jackie Chan.
Like, I thought, like, I don't know, that actually, like, ruined my childhood a little bit when I found out Jackie Chan doesn't even fucking voice act himself in Jackie Chan Adventures.
Wait, you okay, man?
It's some random guy.
Jackie, I'm just a little frustrated, stuck being Winston Zarenborg.
You know, I was making serious bank back in the States.
on we're just paying our dues winston's a loyal guy he'll hook us up when the time's right you can't always wait for the world to hand you what you want sometimes he ain't got time for me as a child it's time to take a little initiative we gotta prove ourselves to winston and the sun on ye or we'll never move up to be fair you didn't have time for it he was i should say that yeah there is dog eyes has a big shipment of stolen goods coming in it's good for dog eyes but that might be too much or too fast.
The last thing I need right now is taking a sticky red pull up my ass.
It's not like that.
It's a small deal.
Word is, there's only a few low-level lunge.
You're looking after it.
We boost that shit and give Winston a nice fat cut.
He's gonna be mad impressed.
No way he doesn't promote us after that.
We'd have to be certain it couldn't be traced back to Winston or us.
Yeah, we gotta make it clean, Jackie.
Unless we get caught.
Well, we won't unless you fuck it up.
Come on, get in.
Time to move up the world all right what do we have to do jackie drive to the warehouse my uncle's a chop shop around the corner call it a pre-stolen ride jackie said we won't get caught i believe oh shit oh it's okay it's very it was one strike three strikes i'm out i'm very safe you're not worried i'm following traffic laws if i let that stop me i'd never ask please thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i love this game it's a class it's cool that you're playing it hope you're enjoying it yeah i'm enjoying it so far it's been really fun maybe the super chat thank you thank you you're one of a guy jackie what's all the crap in the back the hall from my last door baby if i drive on the sidewalk then like i won't do any property damage oh oh see the road is dangerous if i drive on the sidewalk it'll be fine the road is so dangerous guys
that's right give me a sec get me out of here oh hi i like how he calls me ass face time to go to imagination box that's right all right get dumpstered
All right, any other environment?
Oh, wait.
I heard you were electr- Oh, never mind.
Say hello to the Great Wall of China.
I heard you were electrifying.
I don't think there's any more walls.
Oh, wait.
Time to update your windows.
Oh shit, there's more?
Oh.
Alright, don't worry, guys.
I got you.
I need to find, like, more environments.
Is there any more?
No more.
Oh, wait.
Jackie, why are you just there?
Jackie, how?
Oh my god, help the brother out!
Hey buddy, you want to see the Great Wall of China?
All right, let's put him on against the wall.
He's in the zone.
Okay, these guys, okay, this one, I...
I have to like do this because he has a fucking crowbar.
How you like that?
Jackie, you can't fucking say that shit when you're just in the car, Jackie.
Wait.
Jackie, you're not helping.
There's my collection.
All right, it's fine.
There we go.
Do you it?
Because the collection of bloods, that's my favorite.
That's my favorite wall.
Yeah, he's the height man.
He's my passenger, princess.
The wall pile.
I gotta paint that wall red, guys.
It's easier if I use people.
Are you serious?
I have property damage here?
I'm chasing a guy.
I...
Okay, $100 on the meter.
Oh, okay.
Now I can ram.
Okay.
Why does it care about property damage when I'm literally...
Trying to fucking- oh my god, okay, this is not fair.
Okay.
Oh my god, okay, okay, okay.
It's fine.
All right, it's fine.
We got- Oh my god, you guys don't understand, this car is so hard to drive.
They're getting ramped This car is so hard to drive you don't understand Okay, how many escort cars are there?
That's not even my fault!
He ran into me!
Okay Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god Okay, ram the cargo van off the road Oh, no, no, okay, I gotta make sure I don't do property damage.
I have one more strike left.
Oh, my God, please get closer.
Please get closer.
I have to get a little closer.
Oh, all right.
This is fine.
We're so close.
Are you serious?
There we go.
Oh, my God, please.
Are you serious?
He's still alive?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, oh, no, oh, my God, actually, oh, shit, you didn't see that.
There you go.
We did it, man.
We did it.
Hang on.
I'll go get the watches.
I did it.
See, guys?
I still have my one strike left.
Look, it said property debt.
Oh, it was for Cartier watches.
That was crazy, man.
Oh, shit.
We did it, holy shit.
We did it.
Check it out.
It's raining, Capria.
Yeah, Chip and Cartier watches.
Jackie, these are fake as fuck.
Holy shit, Tylo, and the cops drive.
Oh, shit, Tylo.
No, not the Tylo.
Okay, what if I do?
Okay, but why escape where I could do?
Why escape where I could do that?
Get out of here.
Oh, shit.
Can I do any more proper yet?
I'm already being caught by the police.
Oh, no.
No, I have minus five left All right, nice All right, we're good.
We're okay.
Everything's fine.
What do you think will happen with dog title?
I don't know.
He's an asshole.
But he has friends in high places.
All right.
Let's go over here.
Wait, you just got back.
Get to know who's not my fake party and watch it.
I'm working so hard for these things.
No matter who's backing them.
What's that?
Oh no.
Trying to believe dog eyes would turn on a friend like that.
He always was a shit.
Even when we were kids.
Okay, I gotta be careful.
I literally have one life left before I alert the cops.
Oh.
I can't hit anything.
I have one life left for the good guy.
So where's this guy we're meeting?
Don't worry.
I'll take you from here.
You sure you don't want me to stick around?
Oh, man.
I got it under control.
Thank you.
Is this GTA Hong Kong edition?
Yeah, it's basically GTA, but Hong Kong was set in Hong Kong.
Here.
Take this watch.
Yay.
My Carvier.
My Carvier watches.
I prefer a Bolex.
nice I have upgrades my airbrushed dragon armored van I got a fake Cambria watch CIA report on Jackie Ma oh my god $20,000 nice okay, what can I upgrade?
cop upgrades wait, can disarm dual gun-wielding enemies without a struggle receive the phone oh my guys I can't believe I get I'm a big boy now I get a phone Use a slim gym to quickly break in the cars While setting off the alarm Okay I don't need that shit I need Use damage from enemy Extra damage for all striking attacks Okay I need something to do with grapplers Rising kick Eat a slim gym Counter recovery Melee Okay we need Um statues to return your sweep kick knocks down multiple enemies oh i don't want to have that unlocked yet have any face advantage find food and drink this arm we need a this one though okay let's get uh hmm let's take the reduced damage yeah it's like we're not we're not we're not striking anything oh
I'm a bike.
My bike's pretty cool.
Yeah!
If your face is high enough.
Oh shit, do I...
Do not look high enough right now?
What's up?
I was racing earlier and I would have won, but this guy...
My bike is pretty cool.
He cheated.
Ran me off the road at the last minute.
Can you teach him a lesson?
Keep him from doing it again?
Yeah, sure.
He's not far.
Wreck his car.
That'll teach him.
Okay, if I do that, let...
Find a winner's race car before he leaves.
Wait, there's something over here.
Okay, if I do that though...
Does that... Can I do property damage?
Time will wait.
Oh, wait, I'm time?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's fine.
I should be able to get there in time.
Okay.
It's not fake.
Look at this.
They just put it in the random street in the middle of the street.
How is that my fault if I hit it?
It should be their fault for like not putting it away Hello Yeah, that tire iron from the trunk of the car
All right, oh it's time to this wait do I destroy this?
That's fucking right Message from the triads.
That's right.
Your ex-girlfriend is mad at you.
We're not getting the Lubupu she wanted.
Nice.
Oh, that's right.
You think I'm over?
That's right.
Get over here.
All right.
Is there any environments?
Oh, I'm going to fucking bash you in your own car.
That's right.
That's like, you're right.
Get what you deserve.
Alright.
Can I steal your car, too, afterwards?
Uh.
I was going to use...
Wait, actually?
Can I?
Oh, I was going to use her as well.
And be like, going to my car now.
Perfect fitness.
Alright.
Let's see.
I finished that mission.
What's over here?
High speed.
Is that a racing objective?
That has to be a racing one, right?
RB.
Oh, events start.
What event is it?
Is that racing, guys?
Is that a racing one?
I gotta know.
Is that a racing mission?
It sounds, it looks like a racing mission.
A cop job.
That doesn't sound fun.
Oh yeah, no, fuck that shit.
Alright, let's be good for once.
Let's get a cop job.
That sounds so wrong.
It's like a bro job.
But your buddy's a cop.
That's literally what it says!
It literally says cop job!
Right there!
Look!
That sounds awful!
It's a job for cops!
Oh, wait, I'm actually a cop.
We'll see you en route.
Please stand by.
Oh, shit.
I'm like a riot police right now.
That's right.
It's a raid.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Sorry.
What the fuck?
That's fucking right.
Steppy, steppy.
I learned this in America.
Wait, I need that cleaver.
Oh, shit.
Wait, let's...
Give me a sec.
I'm grabbing this cleaver.
There you go.
Chop, chop.
Are cops allowed to do this?
Right.
I learned this from my British boss.
That's okay, right?
Oh, shit.
You're trying to grapple me?
grappler oh wait he's arresting them oh shit sorry maybe i like how my buddies are arresting them and i'm stabbing them you're under arrest do not do not rebel do not resist Brian, cops, do they have it?
Hancock.
Do not resist, I say, with my butcher knife.
Officer Doki returns off her body cap.
Oh, man.
Thank you for the superchatting efforts.
Thank you, thank you.
I got a perfect score, though.
Not very good.
Sales are way down.
Stop resisting.
Hey, could you help me get some new designs?
I want to do a landscape series.
Really capture what's cool about the city.
Yeah, sure.
Give me a couple of classic shots.
Email them over when you have them.
Got it.
Oh, go to the temple.
Oh my god, Dixie.
Okay, what the fuck?
You're going, you're the one that went the wrong way.
How is this my fault?
Alright, here we go.
We gotta go this way.
what's that word when cops do like a drug bust is that i felt like that
to protect and serve josh thank you for the super chat yeah it's a sting operation
all right let's go to the temple i'll confess to my sins and everything will be forgiven the gods will forgive me if i just pray a little at the temple i'm here to protect and serve guys
oh wait going let me steal your shrine first real quick let me steal the holy um oh there's a camera oh wait let me get a good picture first don't worry ma'am there you go uploading Let's up.
Okay.
Wait, does that mean I can always take a picture?
Oh, it was just for that mission.
Go to the hallway stairwell.
Oh my god, it's not evil.
I'm like, wait!
Wait!
I didn't get punished for this!
Oh!
Wait.
It didn't say it was a bad thing that I did that.
God!
Oh my god.
He's fighting back.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
It'll be okay.
He's not dead.
He's okay.
Wait, let me grab him.
Oh shit.
He's fighting back.
Bad boy.
See?
All right, get over here.
There's another one.
Oh, is that hot water?
What does this do?
Tell me where the files are.
It's okay, he works for the triad.
Yeah, why is he fighting back?
I don't understand.
All right.
Sorry, sorry, guys.
For Sydney.
Please forgive me.
Guys, you don't understand.
That's a...
That was a triad member, guys.
That was a triad member.
I have...
done wrong please forgive me it's okay I've repented so this car I just rented this car and she drove it over to my to my place don't listen to what she's saying she's just being a little asleep all right it's this way doing that in the sacred place you understand that was a triad member who was undercover you don't understand I was protecting I was protecting and serving the people.
Sorry, God.
Just a little prank.
Tee-hee.
He dies.
He don't yet.
He was a bad guy, for real.
Alright, we have to go do that thing, the hallway, stairway.
Oh, this car sucks.
This is such a slow car.
I'm gonna steal this car, what can you say?
I think your car's better.
I'm gonna read this card now.
Go listen to what she's saying.
She's just role-playing.
Thank God you guys don't understand what she's saying.
She was saying...
Oh, yeah, no.
If you guys really want to know what she's saying, she was like, oh, okay, thanks for letting me...
Thanks for the tip, sir.
I'll make sure to give you five stars.
That's what she said.
She was like...
She was like, here, sir, here's the card that you ordered.
Thank you.
And I'm like, make sure to give me five stars.
I'm like, yeah, no problem.
I'm sorry.
Don't worry.
Are you guys so lucky that I understand Cantonese and I can translate for you?
Alright.
I had to do here.
Get them in position.
Get what in position?
Oh, take it.
Oh, the sunset.
Where the fuck is that sun what do you mean sunset oh yeah the beautiful sunset in front of me um what a beautiful sunset i think it's the factories from across the board
okay there's some money Wait, that's my...
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Do you want to go for a swim?
Okay.
I don't understand.
What the fuck did I do wrong, dude?
Alright, get over here.
Alright, I'll pick...
Alright, here we go.
This is my favorite pull now.
What?
I pressed Y!
Oh, fuck.
Oh, wait.
That was...
I think his back's broken.
All right.
And another one.
Yeah?
You learned your lesson?
Time to sleep with the fishes.
There you go.
Nice.
Now I can get my money.
Yay!
Oh, it's an Aberdeen!
I like... Aberdeen's a good place.
Alright, let's go.
Sir, what's the closest mission near me?
Oh yeah, there's a beach down there.
Wait, there is a beach down there.
Wait a minute.
Let me check real quick.
Oh,
the bodies are gone.
See, they got up!
the bodies there's no bodies guys see they're okay they're okay there's no bodies that means every they're okay nothing bad happened to them mini bus racket yeah they got better they got up they got up guys see it didn't hurt that bad if they were able to get up
We gotta go...
We gotta...
Converge here.
And then play atoll.
Whoa!
Is that a new massage parlor?
Is that...
Man.
I need to relax soon, guys.
My muscles are aching.
It's been a very long day.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay.
I go this way.
Wait, there's another cop job.
I gotta turn off my body cam real quick, guys.
Give me a sec.
That's the round this one.
Did I do it?
Okay, I was on the job.
I should be allowed to kill at least harm one citizen.
Oh, shit.
It's okay, they dodged it.
I didn't say I meant harm.
I should have at least...
I should be legally allowed to harm one citizen if we're doing a chase.
And be like, oopsie, you know?
It's a little oopsie.
It was an oopsie!
How did I get property damage there?
He fucking hit me!
It was funny.
They died for a good cause.
They should be like...
They're like...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
It was just like...
It was an accident.
It should be...
They died for a good cause.
No, no, he's fine.
It's just... He's fine.
He's in the hospital.
Oh, hey, there's that temple.
Oh!
It's fine.
I think it's fine.
I did it.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Press B.
Why?
Oh, I have to press B again.
Oh, okay.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
You're arrested.
Wait, how do I arrest you?
How do I arrest you?
Oh, my God.
Please.
Please stop resisting.
Stop resisting.
There we go.
You saw that?
How am I gonna...
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, I can bash him in the wall like one time then.
There we go.
And then I can arrest him.
It's just that easy.
Alright, now your turn.
Get down.
Get down from there.
Guys, get down from there.
I need you to stop resisting.
Come on.
Come on, little guy.
Don't make me get the car.
Oh, that's it.
That's it.
There we go.
He saw what happened.
He didn't see nothing.
He's in the name of the law.
No more Mr. Nice cop.
I do my job, whatever it means possible.
Oh, let's get some fish done, Blake.
All right, I'll take it.
Thank you for shopping here.
I'm such a good cop.
I do my job, whatever.
I finished the job.
job no matter what oh shit soup site i get it done exactly
okay to be fair the cop upgrades are dog shit though done good you restored orders in the night market well you took a chance on me Winston i wanted to make sure it paid off you got the right attitude that's gonna pay off for you you know anything about the minibus racket that's right I only care about the results pay the toll that's right you know the pickup on marble drive the most profitable route in the whole fucking city from now on it's yours it's mine thanks I appreciate it Winston dog eyes won't right now it's his route but you know how to deal with it huh it'll be my fucking pleasure of course I know as long as there's a wall i don't want to do don't worry everyone let's go i heard they want to see that great wall of china what's going on we're going on offense taking over more give me a sec let me look at my audio real quick i fixed the audio because whenever i like mute and unmute on go xlr like sometimes it lowers the volume a little oh all right here first stop anybody
gives you oh it's like the green buses i love these little mini buses we're taking the route not declaring war kicking ass is fine by me
it's okay it's just a little property damage the taxpayer the government can pay for this I'll take this one.
Good job.
Yeah, kick his ass.
Who are you?
All right.
Wait, hold on, Gun.
How come we're going after Dark Eyes?
Should we be fighting 18K?
Dark Eye came after us?
This is payback.
Pain and simple.
What if Dark Eyes complains to Big Smile League?
What if he sends Mr. Tong after us?
Look, dude.
What is he gonna do?
But Winston answers the record.
Nobody's going to fuck with the train.
Exactly.
No one's gonna fuck with us.
We know what's up.
Oh, there's two telephone poles.
That's fucking right.
Ring, ring.
Your doctor's calling.
Boom!
Alright, wait, is that another?
Oh, it's time to close shop!
Alright.
Oh, there's one more.
Don't worry.
There's one more.
I'm gonna take you there.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
Not... I'm gonna pick you back up so I can take you to the closed shop.
KK will never be the same.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
But...
You good with your fist?
I'll give you that.
Thanks.
Yeah, we have another guy with us a while back.
with his fist too we ain't done yet the bell didn't ring didn't talk much you remind me of him a lot turned out he was a cop that's why he couldn't kill anyone see so now we know how to spot a rat you know that you know what they do to traders right when tong is done with them wait how many undercover cops were there i thought i was special nobody coming for you they fuck you conroy i still think about that poor sometimes he knows too much I got introduced into a wall.
Oh,
I see some phone booths.
No, no, no, you stay here.
I'll deal with this.
Watch how a real man does it.
Son of a bitch.
But there's so many phone booths!
Hey, you.
You want this route?
You gotta pay for it.
Or ask the rival to make him pull over.
there belongs to Winston now.
Haunt to close I'm gonna harass a bus
I'm gonna
I'm taking his I'm like that's right check out this bus do I just have a Am I like a bus driver now?
How did I become a- Is it because he's a red bus?
Escape the ambush?
Oh shit Don't worry guys.
It's just part of the- it's just part of the ride.
Don't worry We got heated seats Don't worry guys just normal bus behavior just some usual bus rivalry, you know It's just a normal bus robbery.
Guys, don't worry, citizens.
It's part of the tracks, exactly.
Don't you hate it when you're red and green buses?
Start arguing with each other and then start having a little ram fight?
God, I hate it whenever that happens.
I don't want to be a statistic!
I've said that before.
I've actually said that before.
It's part of the experience.
It's just like me.
Man, don't you hate it when you're part of the statistic?
You took the wrong bus.
You should have took the red taxis instead of the green buses.
You should have took the subway, lady.
you guys I'm trying to reverse all right it's this way okay here you go I played these games before they're very happy look how happy my passengers are how the fuck did I stole this buses customer like why did I do that I wait why did you do that way see look how exciting this is did she just say team sad joy
all right nice i was like why did she call it like that team sad joy her what happened hope everything is good my uncle trust you now so you should call them God, I'm in.
Alright.
How do I call him?
I need a sports car.
Let me ask the customer the specifics.
I'll text them over.
Oh, wait.
That's the car thing.
Whoops.
That's not what I wanted.
Uh.
I need a go.
Oh, meet up with Ming.
There you go.
Oh, it's right there.
That's so convenient.
Wait, why is there a person here?
Is that a cop?
Oh.
Can I just, like, hang out with him?
This is harassment.
Wait, actually, I want to know.
Wait, why does he want to talk?
Oh, I can hire him.
Wait, I don't want to hire him.
Oh, the cops don't know.
Oh, he's got a bogeyng, oh?
They see Hala?
Wait, I want to know what happens if I...
Does he care?
You know what I mean?
Oh shit!
Bro, it's okay.
It's okay.
We can get away.
We'll be fine.
It was an accident.
literally guys it was a little bomb it was such a it was such a tiny bomb i don't understand what did i do wrong it was it was just a love tap it was a little love tap guys oh you violated the
It's a good song.
All right.
Find a marked spark.
What's that?
What is that?
Oh, is that the car that he needs?
Oh, it's a sports car.
It's like, what's the mark?
Ways are nice.
all right that's not a sports car
get out of here i need your car
all right that's right you're gonna report to the police i am the police that's right you tried getting a cop job i'm here to give you the cop job
Alright, let's see.
We have to go.
Oh, it's so far.
Okay, I have to give this to...
Oh, the valley is crazy.
What the fuck?
Alright, let's return this car.
Alright.
We got a...
What the fuck?
Someone in my friend's list was, like, scored a beat.
This guy.
Apparently, if I drive for...
Like, drive for 53 seconds straight.
I beat one of the people in my friend's list.
Alright.
Here you go, Tren.
I got you the car.
Whoops.
I still got the car, though.
Oh, shit.
$38,000.
Let's go.
I'm rich.
Alright.
Let's...
We gotta do this.
We gotta...
up with Ming.
Nice.
Oh, this is a nice-ass car.
It feels smooth as hell.
It feels so smooth.
All right, let's go meet up with Ming now.
This game is fun.
I'm having a good time.
I've been enjoying it a lot so far.
I like the melee a lot.
I like that it's not- I like that- Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec, guys.
Hello, sir.
Wait.
Where?
Where is it?
Oh, hey.
Oh.
Where's the ladies?
Wait.
You know what?
Ah.
Okay, you know what?
A massage is a massage, okay, guys?
Oh,
it's a properly licensed?
Guys, it's okay, guys.
Guys, bros gotta help bros out, you know?
Sometimes bros gotta help bros.
Rosella.
You're not.
All right, we got it this way.
Oh, nice.
$55.
You know, the more I think I'll do you a finish with Steven Chow parody of the cop drama Internal Affairs, then even the Super Chat Johnny.
Thank you.
What do you mean?
I'm just getting a massage!
Oh, I'm feeling.
I was just very stressed out.
It's this way.
Oh, it's a noodle shop.
Talk to Ming.
Hello, Ming.
How's you connect?
You getting everything you need?
I haven't been back to Bobstar since I left all guys.
I'm not sure how he's gonna take it.
Want me to talk to him?
Yeah, I can talk to him.
I'm just about out.
So grab my next shipment and make sure everything is cool.
Look, being an undercover cop is hard work.
guys all right we gotta go wait what oh it's inside
i want barbecue duck for dinner i'm gonna get that after oh it was just a long way all right no cops near me wait taxis are faster we actually can hire her oh never mind i can't It's fine.
Alright.
Oh, it's not even that far!
What the fuck?
I didn't even need to steal a car.
Oh my god, it's time to play B-Ball!
Let's fucking go!
It's B-Ball time!
Hey.
What?
When a nice looking boy like you wants with my boyfriend.
Whoa.
I just want a massage.
That's it.
And a pop star?
Who's asking?
Look, I work for Wednesday.
I'm here to bother.
I want to make sure he's supplied sure I'll fix him up, but but what I got to get paid in advance So I'll make it easy for you a couple of deadbeats.
I just owe me money guys.
You should deal for me before they became the own best customer Collect what they owe me and I'll hope you're mad.
Oh, no, you never never get your own product guys You never try your own product Find the deadbeats.
Where are they?
Oh, they're like right over here.
Bro.
Okay, if you're not if you don't want to get caught Don't fucking be next to your dealer Like, that's...
Are they stupid?
Oh, they...
I mean, they did try their products.
Why would you be next to him?
Okay.
You fucked up by being next to a phone booth.
That's fucking right.
Oh, and look at that.
You see what I see here?
You get your wings today.
In heaven.
Alright.
I did it.
Yeah, I was gonna say what...
Oh, is that 7-Eleven?
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's missing.
Quad Mart.
Oh my god.
Hello.
Oh, it's just Dragon Punch.
I was gonna be like, oh my god, a 7-Eleven.
I need a drink after a hard day of beating people up.
Nah, I don't need the soda.
I was like, what the fuck is Miss Quad?
That's me.
One of Winston's guys.
Yeah?
Guess son on you will take on anyone these days.
Get a mean.
Okay.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Who's that?
Thanks, Shen.
Best shit in Hong Kong.
You've got my money?
Got your money.
Here's your package.
Tell Ming to stick with girls over 14 this time.
It's the cops.
Stay cool.
Hey, you too.
Come over here.
Let's go.
Wait, guys.
I think Ming might be a bad person.
Oh, shit.
Lose the cops.
Oh, wait.
That's me.
That's right.
I arrested you.
That's... Oh, shit.
I thought it was like, wait, that's me.
Guys, I think maybe...
Oh, shit.
I think maybe Ming could be a bad guy, guys.
Just maybe.
Who would...
I can't believe it.
The man that works at a try-in might be a bad guy.
Who would, I thought?
That's...
Oh, it's nice that they waited for me to hotwire a car.
That's good.
You don't say.
I'm glad that they waited for me before to hotwire this car.
It's really hard to do, you don't know that.
It's okay, I can get away.
Oh wait, check out, is I a massage parlor?
Does I...
Wait a minute, guys.
Is that a massage parlor right there?
Oh wait, let me...
There we go.
There you go.
Let me just bash him in real quick.
Oh shit, that's okay.
It's just minus five.
Okay.
Oh shit, that's more cops.
Oh, I drove past the police.
Oh my god, guys!
Guys, I fucked up.
I drove past the police office.
Police station.
to run away from the cops do not drive past the police station
all right i did it oh guys give me a sec
guys give me a sec
where is it oh it's the legit one again god damn it
Give me...
Oh wait, it's my phone.
Where am I supposed to do?
It's the same place.
I have to call... Oh, okay.
Inspector Tang?
I got enough to bust Popstone.
But I also met a supplier.
Guy named Fang Shen.
Find out where he hangs out.
And I'll see if I can get something on.
I'll get back to you.
Oh, I gotta bring the drugs to Ming.
You gotta get ketamine.
That's like extra illegal.
I can't believe it.
My homie Ming.
Man, I can't believe he was actually a bad person.
I can't believe it, guys.
Who would have thought?
The man that worked in the Triads done a lot of bad things.
Alright.
That's crazy.
You think you knew a person, too, guys.
You didn't think you would know a person.
Unbelievable.
Alright,
now he...
Oh, my HKPD.
Make contact with the target met Popsar's primary supplier.
I did it.
See, look at that!
I gained cop experience, guys.
Oh my god!
Wait, I leveled up!
Let's go!
I finally got a promotion after 20 years.
Alright.
What can I upgrade?
Okay, I feel like we should fast disarm.
Yeah, I know.
That's actually good.
Okay, I know I have melee training.
Wait, how come I still can't?
Oh, I have to return two more statues before I can do that.
Popstars connect supplies at Lokbu Park.
Use some surveillance.
Okay.
I got that.
Whoa!
They said a bad word.
Yeah, I feel like they're gonna start carrying guns soon.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Sir, sir, taxi.
Taxi!
Oh my god, I don't want to drive.
Wait, this guy.
Wait, how do I...
Where do I have to go?
I have to go...
Where is it?
Where's the blue?
Where's the lead?
Take down.
Oh, here it is.
Okay.
Dixie.
Alright, I'm gonna call a taxi.
I'm too lazy right now.
I have, like, so much money.
Wait.
Hold.
No, that's not what I want!
No, I don't want to drive!
Here, take your own... Here, take it back.
Take it back here.
You can have...
Here, take your tap cap.
Take it back.
Take your taxi back.
Please, I don't want to drive.
I'm so... Please, go back into your car.
Oh, my God.
I started...
final destination all right please sir i just want someone to drive me there please that's all i want please go back to your cab sir get no tanky taxis please it's literally right there i just oh shit they don't get the drop right down k-e-s-s-t no it didn't run k-e-e-s oh wait wait yeah Did anyone snapshot the license plate on that number?
Get the...
It's in and run.
Oh, shit.
Okay, there we go.
Now I can take this cab.
See?
Okay.
Take me here.
Please, sir.
Report him to the police away.
Yes.
Is this fast travel?
Oh, that's just...
Oh, this is so confusing.
Oh, it's only 310.
that's so cheap okay no it's not he he actually like drove me around and around he he drove me to like four different cities before he came back here i got scammed that's actually so expensive he took me to hong kong island before he took me here he went to hong kong island mon kong shatian oh my god he's shaking me what the fuck
Okay.
This is a little bit harder.
Okay, now I can...
What the fuck?
I got his crowbar off and then he...
I got the knife and then he fucking...
And then he pull out a fucking crowbar.
Okay.
This is harder now.
Oh fuck!
Alright, I gotta focus up.
Guys, I have to focus up here.
There's more people now.
Jesus Christ
Get away Okay, I gotta use the environment I gotta get them all out Okay, I can get shanked a little bit That's right, did you see that?
Yeah, that's fucking right, you did That's fucking right, give me that crowbar Yeah, did you see that?
Give me that knife Get out of here Oh, yeah, that's fucking right.
I'm turning the cam off now
That's right shake shake stabby stabby stabby oh it's time to hack the camera.
Oh, it's time Give me a sec I gotta hack the camera.
I'm turning everything off I'm turning all the cams off
How do I unique codes what is this one two three four okay invalid placement oh okay so four three
how there you go one six four three okay oh you guys didn't see oh it's it's word of Use the surveillance feed in your apartment to bust the supply.
All right, next time I'll move myself a little so you guys can see it.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait, let me...
Let me do a shrine real fast.
It was Wordle before Wordle was a thing.
All right, give me a sec, guys.
I got it see I got it guys give me a sec I gotta release some stress again it's massage time whoa I do like some good a good massage girl
oh two for one whoa
one wait there's another one it's like if she was right next to each other give me a sec guys what a good deal i know right okay i gotta compare the experience so i know like which one to go to next time i got i'm a okay i'm a massage parlor reviewer guys how'd you like to take me out you want to regret it i mean who could resist you country way France guys I gotta I gotta make sure I gotta make sure like I go to like the best massage parlor and to find out I have to try all of them out at least once a new job you know oh well it seems not more than one person got a happy ending
Oh See it guys Way's got game They should pay me for a massage for the massage For the privilege to the massage me they should pay me for it Yeah, I should be charging her
All right
Alright, I gotta look at my house and surveillance cam.
But first, I'm Eepie.
I gotta eat.
I had a long day at the massage parlor.
Menace, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm sorry, thank you.
They keep visiting at karaoke park.
Alright, now I can watch the cam.
Alright, Triad activity.
Identify the supplier.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Wait, this is actually pretty.
Oh my god, look at him dancing.
I think...
Okay, I think he's definitely on something.
That guy.
Oh, this is such a...
This is a cool mini-game, actually.
Yeah, I think this is definitely a customer right there.
Oh, I know.
Oh, yeah.
Is it him?
Oh, is it him?
Oh, it's him.
Okay, I have to zoom in.
Ta-da.
Oh, he's like, okay.
Uh, we've identified him.
It's in progress.
Oh, shit!
It's the cops!
Get him!
Oh, my God!
Turn off the camera!
We have to watch the raid.
Nice.
Dr. Tang, this is Wei.
Fangshan is down.
Popstar will have to reach out to another supplier.
I'm thinking we bagged them both at once.
I agree.
If I'm gonna get close to him, I'm gonna need a good disguise.
Can you have your people send something over?
Alright.
They got raided live, yeah.
Live on stream.
It's fucked up.
Who could do such a thing?
I can't...
Wei swatted him!
That's fucked up, Wei!
I can't believe even we swatted someone holy shit we're bad we're not bad people no we're the cops we can do that we're the cops
all right going to the massage parlor is part of the larping guys so they know that i'm a real triad oh shit my bad uh excuse me do you speak english i like to think so not enough to get by anyways You?
Bylaw.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, I speak English.
I kind of guess.
What can I do for you?
I'm looking for this place.
Wait, is this Emma Stone?
Oh my god, is this Emma Stone?
I thought it was around here.
It's supposed to be a Kung Fu school that I'm totally lost.
I have no sense of direction.
Yeah, I think I know where it is.
I mean, it's not too far.
I can give you a ride.
I mean, it'll be easier than explaining where it is.
Uh...
Yeah, that would be really great.
My name's Amanda, by the way, or Amy either one of us Amanda's own I'm way don't you don't just go up to a white woman and say that
Oh, I'm gonna get a motorcycle Oh, yeah, oh wait that is This girl has no fear This girl actually has no fear no, I uh, I just finished college and I'm doing a bit of traveling you know figuring out what to do with my life that sort of thing how's that going well I've only been traveling for a few weeks so no real progress on the life front but I'm checking out Hong Kong though what about you you got it all figured out I wouldn't say that I want here to talk a little bit the band-band club back home I saw a restaurant that looked a little bit like this you could have walked here i wouldn't say that i got a few family issues i'm working on clearing up maybe once that's dealt with wait am i gonna oh yeah we got new photos well the trick to hong kong is learning to live by ancient chinese wisdom wait there's a massage part crossing the street always buckle your seat belt and only apply makeup at red lights don't text and drive you know i can't get off the car
Wait out here.
It's that two for one special!
I was like, oh my god, wait, the two for one special!
Wow.
This is a pretty cool place for a kung fu school.
Unfortunately, the school isn't in the temple.
But not that temple anyway.
Didn't they use this temple as a backdrop for...
Figure one, dude.
What was it, fists of carnage?
No, it was using the grandfathers of the Shaolin Fist.
Whoa.
like you're trying to kill us please okay he was in front of me i don't know what you're talking you don't even have a helmet miss emma stone like why are you judging me you don't even have a helmet you literally got a motorcycle on a fucking stranger's motorcycle and you're telling me about safety isn't this school supposed to be in a temple
What, Seifu?
Can I help you?
Yeah, I'd like to sign up for some Kung Fu classes.
I read about your school in my guidebook.
Ah, your guidebook.
Yeah, it said you teach a style with a long lineage, but in spite of all that, it's still considered very effective.
You want to take classes, okay.
And you, did you also read up?
about this place in some book well i wait i know you hmm yes yes i used to be your student oh that's why i'm so good made it the one who went to america so you brought this girl back the skill level with girls very good now time to assess your skill level in He's like,
good shit, bro.
He's like, bro, good, nice.
Yeah.
Use movement plus X.
Oh, I see.
But why would I do that when I can just scrap her?
Okay, nice.
He's like, you got game, wait.
I see time in America has rusted out.
Oh, it's that.
Okay, but why do that when...
I'm sorry, this...
I know there's like a lot of really cool combos.
But like...
The grapple is just so convenient.
Wait, it won't let me grapple!
A crack grapple inside?
Oh my god, wait.
Guys, they won't let me grapple indoors.
It's like Professor Oak.
There's a time and place for everything.
Apparently I'm not allowed to grapple inside.
I was gonna be like, it's time.
For the one thing that I do know.
Yeah.
Okay.
I did it.
Try to steer them in the right direction.
No grappling in Kung Fu.
But they all want to be Song-ung Yi.
Now I just trained them in the ways of my art.
Try to teach them compassion and discretion.
And pray for the best.
See if I don't think there's much more you can do.
Oh, Jade Rat.
Song Dynasty, right?
Very good.
Song Dynasty?
That's like a thousand years old or something.
Yeah, is that real?
That's real?
Part of a set of 12.
One for each animal.
This should be in a museum, sir.
Yeah.
What happened to the others?
Stolen by a former student corrupted by the triads.
I'm so sorry to hear that sea fool.
Wait, this should be in a museum.
Why do we...
This collection meant a lot to me.
But sometimes you just have to let things go.
I should close up.
It was good to see you again, Wei.
And your lovely fiance.
Oh
Yeah, what do you want to do now?
Oh, you need to get home.
It's a good first day She gave me her number guys I got her number guys I did it.
I got Amanda's phone number or I have one a dog Excellent, I'm in this I was surprised to see you back.
I had hoped that you might have escaped hong kong escaped its influences his problems i'm in with us when we left so coming back didn't change much are you ready to confront them now yes i think so they confront who what would you like to learn oh strike after tackling the enemy wait i can break someone's leg
i'm gonna break somebody's leg actually wait that's cool Alright, I'm spending on that.
Park the truck in disguise in front of...
Strike on this...
Okay.
Oh shit!
That's fucking right.
Okay.
Alright, give me a second, I need to do this.
Wait, why can't I do it?
Why can't I do it?
Oh, there we go.
I have to hold both of them.
All right, I can do it again.
No!
Not disown me.
I'm sorry, Seafo!
Okay.
Strong, like, not limp like noodle.
Okay, that's good.
Okay.
I'm sorry, Seafo!
I'll win for you, Seifu!
OMG!
Oh, sorry, okay, okay, I'll learn for you, Seifu!
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
How much more do I have to... Oh, this guy.
This is the last guy.
Oh, he has a yellow belt?
That's sad.
I'm beating up a yellow belt.
I have one more statue.
I remember I stole another one.
I found one of your statues.
The sheep.
This is good.
promise myself i wouldn't train members of the triads anymore not good for one's karma what makes you think i'm in the triads don't lie to me if there are things you can't reveal don't but never lie how do we talk about the things i can't yeah i'm gonna say aren't i isn't way like a black belt i knew you well once i don't believe people changed why am i beating up yellow belts that's really up appreciate your faith he's like how do you know he's like oh maybe that on you.
All right, leg break.
This is the one I want to learn.
I want to break some legs.
Oh!
I'm gonna break your students' legs.
I'm gonna do it again, too.
Breaking, I'm gonna break your other leg.
That's right.
Oh, again.
Let me...
All right.
It's time to do it again.
See, who wants me to do it again?
I'm sorry.
That's right, right and left leg!
Just do it again, breaking it in eight places!
See who wants me to do that!
There you go.
Breaking all legs today.
Oh, the scream of anguish!
Makes me want to go harder on you.
That's right.
Nobody's going to be walking tonight.
You've got to balance it all out.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I didn't mean to do that.
Let's stop.
This is just training.
It's not my buddies teaching me how to break legs.
That's what Sifu wanted.
All right, where do we go now?
Oh, the golden coil.
Club Bam-Bam!
Who's gonna pay for all of these?
Well, maybe it's on them to stop sucking at this shit.
They're the ones that disappointed the Seifu.
It's their fault for disappointing him.
He's in a guidebook, guys.
He can get as many students as he wants.
now what's going on Winston yes manager of club band band old friend of mine now he's working for dog eyes that ham goton is getting back at us for taking his mini palm god time I'll go talk to Benny make him see reason yeah yeah wait you'll go do that the ham guy I'm got I'm go he's trying to say pervert instead of asshole Jordan thank you this no don't learn that oh shit wait what what does that mean I don't know actually I was like is that is that supposed to be perfect oh shit is this there right thank you for the super chat thank you Thank you.
Please don't say that again.
That's an E.
Oh shit.
I didn't know that's a word.
I don't even know I was like, what is that?
Oh, hams up.
Yeah, hams.
That sounds like hams.
What?
I don't know that one.
What is that for me?
Babe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the ancient Chinese technique for snapping your opponent's Achilles tendon So he never walks right again useful in fights against rival baseball teams you're gonna let me in what do you think you're doing you don't look like you can afford to be here we got standards to keep up what he wants a bribe i'll give you a bra i can't oh okay i was gonna say i was gonna i was gonna teach i was gonna show him what i learned
they're gonna be like there's too many men we need more women in the club sorry bro got balanced the the numbers out bam bam time
benny is the in the vip room wait there was a quick time event oh is that the c oh i did not know that oops oopsie vip okay karaoke the gulag oh my god we're in the gulag
over here I didn't know there was a quick time event I was looking at chat VIPs only What's going on in there This is one of the best karaoke rooms in the city Nobody gets in without a hostess or the boss's approval I'm sure we can work something out Work something out with the hostess Talk to the hostess about getting into the VIP room Oh work something out with the hostess Oh my he doesn't need the money Oh no,
not this mission.
Giga, they give it a super chat.
They can take, oh there's a hostess.
Hey, what's your name?
Yeah.
Hey Tiffany.
You're a karaoke hostess, right?
Can you get me into the VIP room?
Sure.
Just come with me.
Wait, is that easy?
I didn't even have to... Whoa!
Yeah, she...
Whoa!
She was like, no, I don't charge you.
I should pay you for being here.
You mean the manager?
Yeah.
Benny's nice enough.
He always makes sure you get...
Hey, guys.
That's good.
So, uh...
Who does he rely on?
I'm here to sing some karaoke.
Sing me a song.
Sing karaoke for Tiffany?
No problem.
Okay, I only know one awesome Allison.
I only know one Cantonese song.
Dance.
Dance, dance, dance, Monica.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
You, my mom.
How do I play this?
Okay, this is actually...
Law one.
And law one.
I fought the law and the law won.
And the law won.
See, I'm okay.
Oh, guitar is so young.
Let's go.
At the law and the law won.
I fought the law in law one.
Go away go!
Law one.
I fought the law in law one.
I fought the law in a law one.
I did it!
Wow.
Yeah, I'm pretty good.
Listen, no, I like it down here.
But back home, I'm used to a little more.
You'd be the person I talked to about that, right?
I don't know.
Yes, of course.
But I don't.
What a weird mix of fuck up, Mita.
Thank you for the super chat, Gus.
I don't know.
But I want karaoke more.
do it hit me with your best shot I'm gonna hit me with your best shot hit me with your best shot anyway okay I should go back sorry I got you into the karaoke where does she go hello no I can't grab her guys I don't want them to Kick me out karaoke.
I love this place.
I love Club Bang Bang.
I just got here.
But this place is sick.
I don't want to leave Bam Bam.
Oh, hey, there's a dragon statue.
Yoink.
Oh, hey, hey.
Who the fuck are you?
I'm looking for Benny.
I'm Wei.
Hello.
Hey, I'm Paul.
Hey, hey.
What can I do for you?
I have a message from an old friend.
Winston Chu.
What?
Winston?
What that this isn't such a good idea.
I think you should leave he wants you to know that dog eyes isn't your problem anymore If he gives you any trouble you let Winston know and I'll take care of it personally.
He's in a yellow suit I know he's a weasel now I don't trust no no man in the yellow suit Oh shit don't don't make me grab you What the fuck that's right time to sleep with the fishes What the fuck happened to me?
Holy shit, I don't know what happened, guys.
Break your legs, that's right.
Yeah, broke his legs.
Yeah, you saw that?
That's your turn.
Oh.
Oh, get over here.
I'm gonna take him there soon.
What is this?
I don't know what this is that I'm putting you through.
This is important.
Oh, sound check one, two.
That's fucking right.
The fish is new.
You can beat me up all you want.
I'm taking him over here.
Give me a sec.
We're going to travel over there.
This is very important.
Okay.
Here we go.
Not the fish.
What did the fish just do to you?
All right.
There's still one more to check.
We haven't finished, we haven't finished check rehearsals yet.
All right, can we get in the Zoom call real quick so we can check the tech rehearsals?
Danny, get the fuck out of here.
Danny, I know you're in there.
Oh, I'll pick up the fish later Oh shit
Okay, give me a sec I gotta pick up the fish Okay, but I gotta put you against the wall first Give me a sec
All right, slap
Need a need a hand
Is there any other fish?
Oh, there is.
It'll be a shame of your learning seafood!
That's a key right.
Wait, what happened?
What happened to my...
Wait,
wait!
Wait, wait!
Forever kicking his nuts, guys!
Oh shit, there we go!
There we go, I'm okay now.
I-
I like how I'm, like, just kicking his nuts.
Why, where's the rest of the bouncers?
The fish didn't do anything, the horror.
Okay, we're...
Oh, there must be another sound check.
Okay, there you go.
Get this music out of it!
Oh, wait!
Okay, give me a sec.
It's time to turn off the music!
Okay, we gotta get this guy out of here.
Are any environmental kills here around me?
There's still one more.
It's five.
You can beat me up as much as you want.
Okay, I'm gonna break his legs.
Break a leg, as they say!
There we go.
Wait, is there a knife?
Wait, where's the knife?
Shake, shake!
Stab, stab!
Stab, you stab!
That's took you, right?
Oh, wait.
There we go.
You don't need that because we should walk, right?
I think this is my second favorite move now.
Slam dunk!
We're still alive.
Alright.
Are you still alive?
There you go.
He's in the bathroom.
Oh,
I see you.
Avoid grapplers using heavy strike.
shit oh he grappled he reversal me oh
wait he can do that wait wait wait oh the urinal okay i gotta do a quick time for this oh nice okay this guy grapples now i know I know this guy grapples.
Have some cake.
Oh, shit.
Okay, give me a sec.
Buddy, buddy.
Give me a sec.
This is very important.
Wash your hands.
All right.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
All right.
I can't grapple this man.
Yeah, he won't let me grapple him.
That's fucked up.
How to beat him up.
Normally.
There we go.
Relax, Benny.
I'm not gonna kill you.
Okay.
Just listen.
What do you want?
Just what I said.
Winston wants to be your friend.
And what about dark eyes?
That's your problem.
I hope you're right.
Oh, punch and kick the grapplers.
Can I go now?
Of course you can, Benny.
Yay!
Got Tiffany's phone up.
Oh, I got Tiffany's number!
I can call her now.
Meet me at the range location at an hour.
Wait, let me hang out at the Bam Bam Club.
Wait, no, take me back!
I'll go to the Bam Bam Club!
He's got a real hard on.
Is your cover compromised?
Well, you haven't fished me out of the harbour yet.
Alright.
How are you doing?
How am I doing?
Fuck, Raymond.
Where do I start?
There's a civil war brewing in the sun on ye.
Winston and Dog Eyes escalated practically.
Me and Tiffany could have more karaoke time.
Personally, how are you doing?
Look, Raymond.
I gotta get back.
Your state of mind is an important way.
It's important to me.
It's important to how you do your job.
I do my job just yeah and that's for me to decide you mean Pendrew Pendrew assigned me as your controller and listen way Pendrew may not be concerned about you But I am I know you have a personal stake here, but this cannot be a vendetta We're cops There are rules.
You're a cop.
I'm an undercover cop.
The rules are different.
You are not not the same You are an officer of the law way same as me We are not the same how many people did you kill huh?
We done Right, goody two-shoes?
You are not different.
I have to LARP.
Oh, my phone.
This is such a sad bed.
I think the fact that I only have one pillow makes it sadder.
We're really pressed to cycle through.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna call Tiffany.
Tiffany.
How are you?
I'm good.
Listen, um, you busy later?
Well, I'm working.
Oh.
I was thinking of dropping by Bam Bam to see you.
Oh, that'd be great.
You want to sing karaoke?
Yeah.
Well, you have to get a few drinks in me first, but, uh, maybe.
The first thing I do is call Tiffany.
Got it.
Bye-bye.
Oh, my God, guys.
I got a date with Tiffany, you guys.
Look at that.
Do you think she should...
Does anybody tell her about my massage parlor addiction or not?
Oh, I should call Amanda, too.
Amanda, it's way.
You doing anything later?
One in the morning and a date in the morning and a date at night.
You want to come along?
Yeah, cool.
See you in a bit.
Meet me at Victoria Peak.
Yeah, that'd be fun.
See you away.
All right.
Okay, nice.
Now my day's complete.
I have one in the day and one at night.
Okay, where are they?
Is that her?
Oh wait, cockfighting.
Let's go there.
Okay.
Okay,
I gotta cancel all my plans.
Sorry, guys.
I have to...
Ladies and ladies, I'm sorry, I gotta cancel all my plans.
This is much more important.
Alright.
No, I know exactly what cockpointing is.
Sorry ladies.
I got through something very important
We're here.
I'm ready to gamble Hey, what?
Okay, ninja tune road runner records Real FM.
Let's do real FM.
You know it's real All right, we gonna wait I need good songs.
Prang.
How do I get there?
How do I even get through the fights?
Why did they put barriers?
Oh my god.
How the fuck do I get there?
They're like burying it up as if it's illegal or something.
Oh, it's under the bridge.
Okay.
Quit.
Are there any good songs right now?
All right, here we go.
Oh, what the fuck?
Why is the cop doing in the cop fighting ring?
All right.
I'm ready.
Wait, where is it?
Yeah?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, I'm ready.
This is part of the undercover cop thing, okay?
I have to do this.
All right.
Okay, I'm gonna go with the Rhode Island lake.
I'm gonna go with Dokaya on.
Dokaya on.
did he say guys you don't understand guys before i did i didn't use the bathroom before but you don't understand this part of the undercover cop thing okay i gotta do this okay they won't they won't think i'm a real triad if i don't do this guys i swear i have to i've forced you guys the cop i have to do It's for the sake of the case.
This is for the case.
But also needs to back him before I bet.
All right.
I'm back.
Thank you for the super chat.
Smug, Medi, Zechra.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right.
You know what?
1,500.
I'm all in.
He has four wins in.
He's going to go for the eyes.
Come on.
Oh my god, look at him.
Oh my god, he's on top of him.
Wait, that's illegal.
Oh my god, come on.
Dodge that fucker.
Yeah!
Go for the eyes.
I did it!
I fucking knew it!
How much did I get?
Pay out $3,000.
Let's go.
I told you guys.
It's all part of... I'm maintaining my cover.
Make money.
I knew he was a winning bird.
I knew it.
Dinner is served.
I get to eat the loser too afterwards.
It's a win-win for me.
There's a guy over there.
Do I need to help him?
Is he part of Triads?
Jordan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
See, he lied.
He was like, he was like, Mark Cok's the best, but his cock lost.
All right, where do I?
Okay, now I have to go see the ladies.
Okay, club Bam Bam.
All right, Tiffany's son.
Ow.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
guys i'm how did i how do i leave oh it's over here
all right i'll take this motorcycle safety first guys
wait is that their motorcycle give me a sec you're like my motorcycle now i got a date guys i don't have time for you fools i got a date with Tiffany at the Bam Bam Club.
That sounds like my parents when they drive.
I've actually heard that exact phrase from my parents whenever they yell at people for driving.
He's like, Oh, guys, it's a Zataya.
I've actually, that's the exact phrase they would say.
Yeah!
And they'll be like, and then they'll be like, don't learn this from, don't say that to me.
It's so realistic.
It's a true driving immersion.
They'll be like, where did you learn that way?
And I'm just, I just learned it from listening to them while driving.
Where the needle?
Bam bam club!
so smooth I'm here to see Tiffany oh ice cream in Tiffany's club it's in the morning so that oh man this it's it's a lot sadder in the morning not gonna lie not a lie it is definitely a lot sadder it's like going to the strip club in the morning it's a lot sad
Hey, Tiffany.
Oh, you're here.
I've got everything set up.
There's no escaping karaoke here, is there?
You want to sing first?
Yeah!
Wait, is Tiffany Lucy Lou?
Is this Lucy Lou?
Yeah, I'll sing a song for you, Tiffany.
All out of love.
Ruling in the years.
Why is there no Chinese songs?
All out of love.
All right.
Everyone's Lucy Lou
Lying alone My head on the phone Thinking of you Till it hurts I know you hurt too But what else can we do Woo, say a feeling
For times when my life seems so low It would make me believe What tomorrow could bring It is really none, no I'm
so lost without you I know you were right But leaving for so long I'm all out of love When I met you I can't be too late To say that I was so wrong.
Oh,
what are you thinking of?
What
are you thinking, Tiffany?
Go away, go.
I'm all out of love.
I'm so lost without you.
I know you were right, but leaving for so long.
I'm I'm all out of love, who am I without you?
I can't be too late, I know I was so wrong, I'm all out of love, I'm so lost without you, I know you were right, but leaving is so long, I'm all out of love, who am I without you, I can't be too late to say that I was so wrong.
This is our first date, by the way.
He's gonna start crying.
This is our first date.
Early morning singing.
Is there anything you'd like me to sing?
No, thanks.
Maybe next time.
I should get going.
Really?
So soon?
You want me to sit on your lap and sing for you?
Oh!
That's the kind of thing clients usually...
Wait, am I a client?
I'm no client, aren't I?
Put it like that.
Let's go sing.
You ready to go crazy?
I'm a pro.
Try to keep up.
Why is it... Why did it zoom into the face wash?
A cheese paste.
Oh, I'm face level too!
Hey, do I have more karaoke?
Oh my god, I can sing by myself.
I don't need her.
Why are you all like I love so...
Alright, how do I leave you?
Oh, it's starting to get...
Oh my god, wait, it's a nighttime?
Is that how long I've been singing for?
Oh my god, I sang till nighttime.
Oh my gosh, I hope Amanda wasn't waiting too long.
It's okay.
I never said what time I was gonna go see her, guys.
I never said what time.
Wait, why can't I get on my bike?
Alright, let's see.
Wait, where's Amanda's?
Oh my god, it's so far.
I'm going to get a taxi.
Fuck this.
Okay, where's the...
Alright, I need to stand in front of a taxi real quick.
This is too far.
Alright, I'm going to block this.
Alright.
It's okay.
She doesn't know.
Alright, take me to Amanda's...
I think it's here.
I'm pretty sure.
I can't...
Are you serious?
Okay, wait.
If I go...
Okay.
We'll go to...
Okay, what's the closest?
The parking.
We'll go to the parking.
And then...
And then I'll...
I'm gonna steal his cab.
And now...
Now I can go to Amanda.
I There you go It's just that easy Okay There you go Naturally you know I gotta get a ride Bro that's it Thanks to Thanks to the cab bro
It's just that easy
See This is why you should Yeah, this is why I should keep the child's safety locks on.
Alright.
Park- Yeah, but I have to walk like five more steps to access the parking lot, guys.
Why do that when the taxi was literally next to me?
But, um...
Okay.
As long as I don't do anything illegal next to the cop, it's fine.
But, um, bum, bum.
Oh my god look she wore a date outfit this is a date hello um being a taxi driver is like one of my five side jobs I didn't steal it you look frustrating what's going on it's closed Ricky thank you for the super chat thank you weekends this sucks I wanted some pictures for my blog Let me see what I can do.
Don't worry.
I got you I'm a cop.
You know how I was talking about writing a book.
Oh my god, bro.
This is the first day
Hey, you want an ice cream?
Hey girl.
Oh, I am a good boyfriend.
Look at that.
See?
I know how to take a good picture She wanted the fountain, right?
That looks good.
I have to say, that dress looks really good on you.
Well, you know, this guy...
It was good.
Thank you.
I know.
I know it was a good picture.
Guys, I gotta be realistic.
I gotta... I gotta be immersive, you know?
You know that tweet where they're like, girlfriend, girlfriend pictures versus boyfriend pictures?
in that tweet where like they compare like you know how like the girlfriends would like have try to have like the uh make sure it's like the best picture possible and then the boyfriend would just be like snap i think i got it i'm just trying to be immersive here
all right here's a bribe you think you can let me in my friend in no I told you it's closed.
Look, I'll make it worth your while.
Don't call us out like that.
You're so resourceful, way.
What the fuck?
Can you take some pictures for me?
Please?
Okay.
I don't appreciate the calling out.
Don't worry, girl.
I've got you.
Oh, that's pretty.
See, she said it's pretty, guys.
Why did I run, like, mock Aiden to?
I think this is a good spot.
Oh, I got you, girl.
See?
It's a good composition!
Look at that!
She wanted the picture of the gates, right?
Like, bro, she gets us.
She wanted the fence.
All right.
What does she want?
Okay.
I will have an actual good photo.
You're a pretty good photographer.
No problem.
My pleasure.
That was great.
Thank you so much.
I can't believe you got us in here.
That's no problem.
I mean, it was fun.
Kind of, you know, nice playing tourist in your own town.
Yeah, I can see that.
She called me a good photography.
Taking the time to.
You know, do this.
It's okay.
So, uh, was this, like, a good date?
Sounds good to me.
What do you think?
Definitely.
She said it was a good date.
She likes all my photos.
The accurate boyfriend experience.
Oh!
I did!
I got the fourth base!
A home run!
Look at that.
Whoa.
What were you doing in the car?
I thought that was it.
Is that not home run?
There's more to it There's more to a home run?
There's oh my gosh, you know what?
I got some today.
I'm gonna grab some ice cream to celebrate Tribute for a dragon head toky.
Yeah, I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you
Post kiss a post kiss ice cream
oh my god all right we heard the post yeah it's called i'm oh my god i'm doing victory lap yeah celebrate with a massage there's something that comes after kissing i gotta read what i have to read what's her name amanda there you go subject was absurd with serpent on why why do i have a police why did i have a police report on on filed by Winston why did Winston put a police report on Amanda no criminal record or no criminal association traveling on tourist visa has applied to several ESL schools reveal job application reveals that Kara has exaggerated and her fabricated her experience in this field limited physical surveillance conducted on as an available basis over two week period no suspicious activity observed Cedric is seen learning with and are romantic associated with several other males of Chinese origin Oh,
she has a type Wait, I'm not I'm not just me Recording officer observes that this may reflect a romantic bias or sexual preference Oh I'm not special How many other buff-ass tattooed Asian men is she dating?
That was also from America and knows Kung Fu.
There's more of us.
What about Tiffany?
What about, oh, I don't have a fucking report on Tiffany, but I have a report on Amanda.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm just I'm just a fetish.
I thought we had something They're all and they're also undercover.
I thought we had something special I'm just like everyone went broken by thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
We went to a park together I'm so sad Love is a lie.
I bribed a man a thousand dollars for this.
I can't believe it.
Never trust Emma Stone.
I knew it.
Ever since she fucked over...
What's his name?
Ever since she fucked over Ryan Reynolds and La La Land.
I knew it.
Never trust Emma Stone.
I gotta get to a massage parlor.
Alright.
Ryan Gosling.
There's so many riots.
Ever since she betrayed Ryan Gosling in La La Land.
I fucking knew it.
She's a witch.
Only one thing can cure my heart.
The massage parlor will eat you.
my soul but I knew it how could she break Ryan I knew it I was like how could she ever break Ryan Goshen's heart like that he did everything for her he did everything she wanted to be an actress and he did everything for her I knew it She never changed
She used me I Got it That's it only one thing can cure my heartbreak That's not how la la I knew Tiffany was the one she never betrayed me Give me a...
Guys, please, I have...
God damn it!
Fuck it!
This is...
Whatever.
Please, I need...
...expecting.
What?
Please, I need...
Please, I don't care anymore.
I'll take any massage.
Please!
I'm going through heart...
Oh my god, they...
Please, we need it.
I'm going through heartbreak right now!
They're so fucked up, they won't give me a massage.
I'm desperate.
Get out of here.
I'll go to the next available massage.
You think I need you?
I'm a customer's favorite.
I'm a massage connoisseur.
I can just replace you.
Just like how Amanda replaced me.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
They'll all betray you eventually.
But the massage parlor will always be there for me.
It's okay, I know.
I know where there's...
I know where there's the closest massage parlor.
Mr. Broken 5, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Need a man's hand because a woman's hands are cold and heartless Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you Alright, we're almost there We're almost there There's a one place that would never betray me
I'm almost there Okay This is what?
There we go.
I'm almost there.
Alright.
This is more important.
Amanda used to call me sexy.
Might as well try everything once, right?
At least you'll always be here, right?
See?
There she is waiting for me.
She won't betray my heart.
I'm her only client, right, guys?
I'm pretty sure I'm her only client, too.
That's what she told me.
She said I'm special.
How do I...
Oh, there you go.
Yeah.
She said she only does this for her favorite client, and I'm just me.
guys she gives regular massages to all the other ones but for me i'm special i'm her special special man okay
wait for pop star in the chicken van all right it was one day she baited me
oh what the what the fuck
What the fuck happened here?
I don't think that was supposed to happen.
You would think she...
I don't think that was supposed to happen there.
You would think he's suspicious if I do that?
Oh, shit.
Okay, I just need to, like, not get hit.
Just another day in Hong Kong, you know?
Okay.
So that's why I don't get my car hit.
It should be fine.
I'm my heart's broken.
It's time to do a drug bus.
I need to get you a cop job to mend my broken heart.
Is this a sus if you drive on the other side?
I don't think so.
Guys, I think it might have been suspicious that I drove on the other side.
Okay.
He's not even driving on the fucking road.
How am I the bad person here?
Okay, we're here.
Fribs, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Okay, because I'm on the route.
Don't worry, I have a hat.
They won't know.
Ooh.
Is he going to know?
What if I, like...
Okay, wait, I'm curious.
What if I just look at the...
like this does it still work
i did it standing man emoji guys do you think they know i'm then right in wait
what happens if i wait actually what happens if i
okay okay i was curious i was curious i was curious I don't know if it works.
Okay, I know this works.
I get caught.
Okay, that makes sense, you know?
That makes sense.
I thought it would work the entire time!
Okay, here you go.
What happens if I stack?
And in the open.
I like how they don't notice me.
Just jump down and just stand there.
Okay.
I got him.
Got him.
I'm just mad.
Standing mad emoji.
I spy with my little eye.
A drug dealer.
Do you spy?
Do you see a drug dealer right now?
Where is it?
There it is.
That's a drug deal.
Wait until Popstar Crew head to the...
Right there!
Bombinos!
Wait, who is the guy I have to follow?
Wait, what?
Oh.
You did it.
Muy bien.
Fucking bitch.
I can't do that.
Can't do that to me.
I live here.
I'm gonna sleep.
Get to board.
I should get an Oscar for this.
Oh
my god.
I can vomit on command.
Holy shit.
Oh wait, she's bomb.
He's like, oh my god, no, I can't do that.
Oh my god, damn, Wei.
Why the fuck did he decide to be a cop?
Could be an actor.
Yeah, that's a method actor right there.
That's crazy that he could just do that.
Wei is 100% committed.
Hey, drunken master.
Let's go.
Yeah, you see what you're missing out?
Shout out Amanda!
Yeah,
they're not from Seafood.
It's okay, I got the photo before he died.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should have called...
Maybe I should have called it when he photographed it when he killed him.
Just down the drug pipeline at least.
And I'm giving you pop star on a platter.
I got the deal and the double cross on camera.
There they go.
Goodbye.
Whoa, parkour.
You just killed him like that.
Oh, I'm clumsy.
How did I get minus five?
Because I...
Oh, because I made a fool of myself.
Like, cops don't just ram in the things.
That's such a good score, too.
to my chicken chicken truck i'll never know my little chicken car to the undercover hq wait a cop was there the entire time are you serious what did i do wrong i don't know what i did wrong i don't i don't know what i did wrong i Fuck off.
I'm just a little chicken truck!
Alright.
It's fine, I still have three stars.
I'm just a little chicken truck.
I'm just so, I'm so harmless.
We've charged Popstar and his top lieutenants.
Conspiracy, trafficking, possession, and murder.
Obtain murder and drug evidence.
Oh, nice.
I've done more to stop drugs coming into Hong Kong than half the narcotic squad combined.
I did it.
Yay!
I'm a good cop.
Let me go.
Jackie was gonna be proud of me.
Death of Officer Charles Ho?
Who's Officer Charles Ho?
Okay, let's see.
Form a rising strike.
We'll do that.
That looks cool as hell.
Now I can.
Okay, we don't need slow mode.
Let's get a slim gym.
What's this?
Perform an action hijack while being chased.
Increased ramming damage.
Yeah, I feel like I break into a lot of cars.
Okay.
Wait, what's this?
What's over here?
Oh my god, it's a fucking racing thing again.
Let's see.
Oh, I just have Jade statues.
Oh, did I do all of it?
Oh, never mind.
Winston wants to talk to me at the restaurant.
Meet Winston.
I got used my slim gym.
Yay!
I can't.
Pumpin.
Pimpin.
I keep it pimping.
All right, let's go.
Before we do that, before we do that, I got him in a broken heart.
The only way I know.
The only way I know to fix a broken heart.
Wait, do you think Tiffany will answer my call?
Oh, it's just trash.
Never mind.
No, I gotta let out this anger inside me There's other ways to mend a broken heart It's not just a massage parlor Guys, there's other ways to fix a broken heart
I've cleared my head But I'm still filled with anger So there's only one thing I can do.
That's right.
Put you in the trash like how she put me in the trash.
That's fucking right.
No one's gonna call you like she stopped calling me.
She wouldn't even ask her back.
Hello!
Can you fix a broken heart?
Alright.
It's okay.
I'm taking the law in my own hands.
And let out.
Do you want to talk about it?
I don't need to talk about anything.
Alright, don't worry.
I got it.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here!
She liked that wall too.
Did you guys know that?
Oh shit.
Okay, I gotta be focused.
out that's fucking right I got out I can get hose I can get hose that's fucking
right that's right that's right I should have stayed in the bad bad club all right nice there we go I feel better now.
They don't deserve it.
Don't care.
I feel a lot better now.
Amanda who?
I don't know who she is.
She cheated those guys.
There was like a camera so I could hijack.
Where's the camera?
Oh, whatever.
Let's go talk to Winston.
It's all right.
You know who won't betray me?
You're right.
Only a pork bun can make me a whole man.
Nice.
There we go.
He's right.
It'll make me a whole man.
I don't need no woman for that.
All I need is my pork bun.
Pork buns will never betray me.
They'll be there for me no matter what.
The bow vendor would never hurt me.
That's right.
Not a fetish for him.
Alright.
Winston.
Thanks.
It's fucking great.
But you're on my side.
We've been waiting for you.
You guys smell something?
I don't know what.
The fourth one?
It's like sexy.
Oh, sure.
Huh?
You know what happens to rat sway?
I'm not a rat.
Conroy gave me all the details when he was helping me out on that minimum.
Whoa!
You're so sad.
Who the fuck do you think you are?
Huh?
You come in out of nowhere and suddenly our guys start to get arrested?
He ran it out, Popstar, Winston.
I know he did!
All you gotta do to run!
This motherfucker right here is a snitch!
Is that right, Ming?
For you fucking wrath.
I sent you to Popstar.
But now he's in jail!
Yeah?
And who stands to gain the most from that?
You're gonna take over Popstar's whole ketamine racket now.
No more scraps for you.
You'll supply the whole city with drugs.
You and Dog Eyes.
Popstar's gone.
You're still dealing, aren't you?
So who's supplying you?
That's a golden deagle.
Is it one shot?
Actually, listen to this asshole.
He's a rat.
He's a fucking rat.
He's still looking for that bastard orange.
I mean, where's that?
Oh, he's a dirty fucking thing.
Oh, my God.
Speech 100 right there.
Oh, God.
It was one shot.
Look at that.
He disposed a gun.
way never forget that you get in this business for yourself you're bound to end up like later long time jesus i'd like speech a hundred myself out of that
wait is he feeling guilty that guy was on ketamine why would you feel guilty about that Bro, he's a...
He was a full-on.
He was a UZ.
Oh, his PTSD.
Yeah.
Okay.
Apostle murder in the race scene.
Let's talk.
Alright.
Where are my surveillance?
Do I have anything else?
I don't have this.
Oh.
Nothing else is going on on my cam.
Yeah, he's so...
Can I mean the kids, guys?
He talked to children.
I think it's okay that he's dead.
Wait, I don't think you should feel any guilt about that.
Not gonna lie.
You should definitely not feel any guilt on that guy dying.
All right, we're gonna call it.
Oh my god, we've been playing for...
Holy shit, Chad.
We've been playing for four hours.
call it here because I have to be up at 6 in the morning tomorrow but that was really fun I had a lot of wait can I call Amanda wait give me a sec guys sorry wait wait wait I got a phone call wait can I call Amanda god damn it okay never mind never mind guys I swear I'm over her wait wait what's on my I swear I'm over her guys I was like oh my head is Amanda gonna call me is she I'm so over here.
But that was really fun!
I had a great time playing um playing sleeping dogs so far.
I really like the story.
I'm at the I really like the story so far and like the ambience and basically like the environment of everything.
Um it really does remind me of other than the triads part.
It reminds me it reminds me of Hong Kong in terms of the environment and like the people, the things people are saying.
other than the triads part and the massage parlor it reminds me of hong kong
um but um i had a great time playing um i'm gonna call it it's gonna i'm gonna call it now um there's no super chat reading today because like i said my voice is still pretty up at the moment um it's still recovering um and like i've been muting my coughs and taking cough drops throughout the the stream um so i'm gonna rest a little bit before my stream tomorrow uh as always everybody stay hydrated posture check give them around to get that blood floor and if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye